[musique]
John de Laoren, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Bien, je
m'appelle John de Laoren, j'ai 35 ans.
Euh, j'étais un ancien cadre en finances
et j'ai décidé de tout arrêter pour euh
me battre pour mes idées, les intérêts
français parce que je pense qu'ils sont
très importants. Et euh je remercie,
j'en profite pour remercier tous les
gens qui m'aident depuis des années,
même ce récemment, ceux qui me
soutiennent depuis le début. et je passe
un message à ma femme et à ma fille que
j'aime de tout mon cœur. Voilà,
on a décidé de vous faire venir
aujourd'hui parce qu'on vous suit sur
Twitter, du moins vous apparaissez dans
notre fil Twitter et on a remarqué que
vous aviez relevé le menton et que vous
aviez décidé en fait de d'expertiser la
situation de la France et donner votre
point de vue. On nous demande tout le
temps de faire venir des gens entre
guillemets lambda ce que chose qu'on me
fait très rarement. Euh vous êtes pas
quelqu'un de monda parce que vous avez
décidé de relever le menton et de
regarder les choses dans les yeux sans
lunettes rose. Première question,
qu'est-ce que vous faisiez dans la
finance ou qu'est-ce que vous faites
dans la finance ? Quel est votre
background ? Qu'est-ce que vous, quel
type de produit vous utilisiez ou vous
manipuliez ?
Alors moi, j'ai fait des études comme
beaucoup de français, tout ce qui est
bac bac + 5 et j'ai surtout travaillé
dans la trésorerie. Donc ce dont on se
rend compte même avec les études, c'est
que en allant dans le travail, on
apprend à utiliser des systèmes, à
travailler en collaboration avec des
gens et moi c'était spécifiquement sur
la trésorerie, gérer des budgets, gérer
la prévision financière pour un groupe,
voir évidemment comment améliorer le le
la gestion de ses finances.
Et euh à un moment donné, je me suis
bien rendu compte que tout ce qui se
passait au niveau politique, ce qui me
semblait vraiment à des années lumières,
même si je toujours été passionné depuis
des années et bien suivre ce qui ce qui
s'est déroulait, on se rend vite compte,
même sans le vouloir, que la politique
vous atteint directement. Et c'est ce
qui m'a fait prendre conscience, c'est
surtout durant la crise sanitaire. Je le
savais déjà avant parce que je pense que
beaucoup de personnes ont fait ce
constat. Ils ont très bien vu Maich à
l'époque, surtout le référendum de 2005
où les Français ont dit non. Ensuite, on
a vu la trahison, je pense que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut l'appeler, du traité
de Lisbonne et où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui. Donc de part mon mon
expérience, de part mes mes relations au
travail et de mes amis, on se rend vite
compte que par moment, moi
personnellement et je pense que beaucoup
de gens le partagent, on peut pas
simplement s'attendre à ce qu'il y a des
représentants politiques ou dans les
médias en espérant que sa voix soit
relayée, qu'on puisse avoir les
informations que l'on souhaite avec le
ton et l'œil qu'on souhaite également.
et j'ai décidé à un moment de le faire
de le faire par moi-même. Voilà, je
pense que c'est ce que fait aussi
Finkerview de faire ses interviews,
d'avoir une communauté. C'est toujours
important les gens qui sont derrière,
les c'est je dis véritablement he les
gens qui sont derrière qui poussent le
le travail sur le fake viiew de moi-même
ou bien d'autres, c'est primordial
puisque c'est ce qui fait de continuer
dans un écosystème politique et
médiatique qui est très difficile et je
pense que de plus en plus, moi
personnellement, je pense que nous
sommes énormément et de plus en plus à
vouloir un changement et il faudra le
faire par nous-même. Voilà.
Si vous ne vous occupez pas de la
politique, c'est la politique qui va
s'occuper de vous. Euh
quand vous avez pris conscience qu'il y
avait un souci, est-ce que vous êtes
rentré en en en contact avec les
politiques ? De quel spectre est-ce que
vous avez rencontré tout le spectre
politique ? Est-ce que vous avez cherché
à les sonder à comprendre s'il
maîtrisait les sujets que vous vous
connaissiez sur le bout des doigts ?
Est-ce que vous êtes rendu compte queils
étaient soit cortiqués pour pouvoir
mener le pays ou soit que c'était des
boutiquers complètement vides à bleur à
aranguer leurs adeptes euh pour pouvoir
exister et avoir du pouvoir ?
Moi pour être franc, j'ai toujours une
sensibilité de de droite. Mais
ça veut dire quoi une sensibilité de
droite ? Parce que c'est vrai que tout
est dévoyé aujourd'hui. Vous avez des
gens qui disent "Je suis de gauche, je
suis de droite, d'extrême gauche,
d'extrême droite." Moi ma conception et
normalement c'est celle qui est euh de
la définition. La droite c'est toujours
avec les valeurs conservatrices,
toujours de faire du business euh mais
il faut pas être secctaire non plus, que
il faut savoir parler à enfin il faut
sortir du du spectre politique quand on
parle à ses amis ou sa famille. Vous
avez des gens de gauche, vous allez pas
les mettre dans une case parce qu'ils ne
pensent pas comme vous. Donc je pense
qu'il faut discuter avec tout le monde,
mais de moi, de mon engagement et de qui
avec j'ai de qui avec j'ai de qui j'ai
discuté, pardon, euh c'était beaucoup
plus à droite. J'ai aussi toute une part
sur le souverainisme. Moi, je pense que
la la liberté de la France parce que je
me bas beaucoup sur les idées de la
liberté, c'est tout. On en parlera
peut-être probablement tout à l'heure
sur
avec une grande certitude.
Voilà, c'est tout ce qu'on parlera sur
les réseaux sociaux et un petit peu ce
qu'on essaie de faire. Euh et surtout
pour moi ça s ça ça se ça se fédère et
ça ça s'implique dans la souveraineté.
La souveraineté c'est beaucoup de
choses. C'est pas simplement comme on
peut l'entendre sur l'immigration
l'identité. Bien évidemment que ça en
fait partie mais il y a sur l'aspect
économique, il y a sur l'aspect de la
liberté individuelle euh et géopolitique
et de de diplomatie qui qui en découle.
Et donc de toutes ces idées-là, moi
c'est plutôt sur le spectre de droite.
J'ai été à plusieurs rendez-vous dans
des fédérations et ce qui est très
intéressant, c'est que je peux faire le
lien avec le parcours professionnel.
Quand on va dans un parti politique, on
arrive, c'est des réunions, vous avez
des gens, vous discutez avec eux et au
final, vous avez toujours le responsable
du local ou le responsable de fédération
et c'est toujours à plusieurs niveaux.
Vous pouvez faire le parallèle avec le N
+ 1, le N + 2, le N + 3, le manager, le
trésorier comme là où je bossais avant.
Et euh ils sont toujours tenus en fait
par leur carrière personnelle ou par ce
que le parti leur impose. Ou alors euh
vous avez des gens souvent
malheureusement qui sont incompétents
parce que dans leur famille euh il y a
des liens avec la tête du parti ou la
tête d'une société et on peut tout de
suite être bloqué. Le problème aussi de
la société, de ce qui se passe au niveau
politique et dans les entreprises, et je
trouve que c'est un gros problème parce
que la solution viendra de nous, euh
c'est que les gens voient les autres
comme des menaces. Voilà, c'est il y a
toujours une une sensation, des
attaques. Euh la vous voyez vraiment le
contexte d'avoir le la proie et le
prédateur. Euh et euh dès que quelqu'un
sent qu'il va se faire dépasser
justement par une nouvelle personnalité
ou euh juste quelqu'un lambda parce que
moi je considère que je suis lambda de
base, je je veux pas me mettre au-dessus
des autres, ça n'a strictement aucun
intérêt. La seule façon, comme vous le
disiez, c'est de lever le menton et on
se rend bien compte que la mêlée où tout
le monde se bat, essaie de faire quelque
chose et dès que vous mettez la tête
au-dessus, vous devenez une cible. Donc
c'est là où est tout le danger.
Euh voilà. Donc dans les partis
politiques, le problème c'est le
suivant. C'est-à-dire que vous avez des
intérêt personnel qui se mettent en même
temps avec un discours national ou
universel. Si on est à gauche, le centre
mélange un peu le pire des deux et on on
se bloque tout de suite en fait face à à
un mur où les gens ne ne vous
comprennent pas. Et j'ai un exemple très
simple. Moi, j'étais allé à des réunions
de plusieurs partis politiques de droite
où je leur expliquais à l'époque,
j'avais juste mon compte à 4 5000
abonnés. Les gens me rigolaient au nez.
Voilà, il me rigoler au nez. Euh et je
leur expliqué, ça c'est un outil, c'est
le seul espace de liberté que nous avons
encore aujourd'hui où on peut passer nos
idées en fait sans intermédiaire. On
peut montrer là où les choses se
passent, mettre des chiffres, des
chiffres économiques, des informations
géopolitiques. On peut tout mettre en
fait sur les réseaux sociaux. Alors
évidemment, certains vont parler de
désinformation, d'autres vont parler de
propagande, mais finalement aujourd'hui,
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui fait la
propagande ? Qui fait du débunkage ? Qui
fait de la désinformation ? La question
qui les finance,
voilà, qui les finance. Moi, je le
répète, il y a absolument personne qui
me finance. Je suis libre de ma parole.
Euh et euh d'ailleurs, je sais pas si ça
vous est arrivé aussi, mais vous avez
des gens qui viennent avec des questions
pernicieuses qui essayent de vous de
déterrer comme s'il y avait un financeur
caché qui essaie de vous déstabiliser et
cetera. Et
c'est une question que vous nous posez
là
sur les finances parce que sur les
finances, nous on a anticipé ça dès le
le premier jour de la création de la
chaîne. On prend pas les Bitcoin, on
prend pas les coins pour éviter qu'on
nous dise où on est financé dans les par
des puissances ou quoi que ce soit. Euh
nos finances sont transparentes à 100 %
sur Tipi. Euh on a une une expert
comptable, un expert comptable euh
extraordinaire. On vit comme des moine
et euh on met un point d'honneur à avoir
Je confirme hein pour vivre comme des
[rires]
on met un point d'honneur un point
d'honneur à avoir des finances carrées
parce que on veut pouvoir aller les
chercher sur leur terrain. Excusez-moi
de vous avoir coupé d'ailleurs.
Profitez-en pour nous soutenir sur Tipi.
On a besoin de vous. C'est grâce à vous
qu'on a de l'indépendance et notre
communauté nous finance sur Tipi. John,
continue.
Ce que je voulais ajouter aussi, c'est
que je pense que ce qui a disparu
aujourd'hui dans la société, c'est
l'authenticité
et la sincérité. Voilà, moi j'ai à un
moment donné, j'ai eu la chance et
encore une fois, c'est pas parce que il
y a des gens cachés qui m'ont aidé ou
quoi que ce soit, ce sont des des gens
qui étaient en lien un petit peu avec ce
qui se passait à SU. J'ai pu aller sur
cette chaîne, j'étais extrêmement
content. Ça a fait à un moment donné un,
ils m'ont montré les statistiques où ça
montra plus de 800000 au moment où je
passais, où les gens venaient,
repartaient et j'ai reçu vraiment des
milliers de messages. Et ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre, c'est que c'est pas
simplement des gens de droite ou
forcément politisés ou et en fait on
reçoit énormément de de choses
positives. vraiment le négatif est même
pas du 1 ou du 2 % et on se rend quand
même bien compte qu'il y a véritablement
une âme, une envie des Français qui dit
"Je me rends bien compte que ce pays ça
ne fonctionne pas bien. Je vois que vous
êtes jeunes, c'est super, moi je suis
trop vieux ou alors je suis en finance
et j'ai envie de faire comme vous ou
j'ai fait comme vous, je me suis
expatrié."
Quel âge avez-vous ? Moi, j'ai 35 ans.
Et en fait, vous vous rendez vite compte
que
c'est comme ça que je l'explique à
beaucoup de personnes, euh la volonté,
elle est là, l'envie, elle est là, la
dynamique, elle est là. Simplement,
c'est la représentation qui n'est pas là
en fait. Si vous proposez un projet
politique au français qui soit clair en
disant que ça soit libéral et
conservateur, je peux même m'entendre
avec des gens de gauche, il y a pas de
souci. C'est je pense que les gens
intelligents sont capables de passer
au-dessus du dogme politique pour
pouvoir euh trouver un consensus parce
que ce qu'on manque aussi dans cette
société, c'est qu'on est tellement
divisé et fracturé que les Français sont
dans des cases, ils ne discutent plus
ensemble alors qu'on est dans un moment
où la France devient une proie dans un
contexte très difficile et que il faut
avoir un peuple soudé, ce qu'on
l'empêche de faire depuis des années. Et
c'est pour ça que moi je suis prêt à
parler avec tout le monde là-dessus euh
et que
c'est mon ressenti et je pense que c'est
sincère euh qu'on essaie de l'en
empêcher. À partir du moment où on
passera au-dessus de ces dogmes, on
partira on passera au-dessus des partis
politiques, qu'on discutera des faits
économiques euh social, même le fait de
l'immigration parce que ça ça peut
déranger un spectre de politique mais ça
se discute dans d'autres démocraties
européennes. On le voit, on pourra
arriver à une solution qui fera que
quelque chose se passera. Euh et encore
une fois, les réseaux sociaux sont une
solution. Le problème, c'est que à un
moment donné, on constate bien que j'en
suis prisonnier également, hein. Les
gens me le reprochent euh et je l'assume
complètement par moment. Il va falloir
faire des choses qui buzzent, des choses
qui soient claires, mais en même temps,
vous pouvez aussi travailler sur des
révélations, sur des
offs donner à un avis qui n'existe pas
pour que ça puisse donner de la
visibilité. Et la grande force en fait
différence des médias mainstream ou des
politiques, c'est que si derrière vous
avez le flux, les gens qui sont derrière
vous qui vous poussent en fait à pousser
une idée, à la fin tout euh le camp d'en
face, on peut l'appeler comme ça ou le
système, certains le disent, moi j'ai
pas de problème à le dire. Euh eux qui
ont tout tous ces financements, euh tout
le système qui est en place qui leur
permet de continuer, si der ils sont
tenus en fait par le clic sur les sur
les articles, ils sont tenus par la
représentativité dans les urnes pour
pouvoir avoir leur légitimité. Mais si
vous vous êtes là que vous créez plus de
d'interaction, créez plus de visibilité,
plus d'impact, plus de commentaires,
plus de gens qui se mobilisent pour une
cause, ils sont obligés de le prendre.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Le pipe,
le tuyau euh du média non mainstream, le
média alternative, le blog, la
plateforme, on peut vous débrancher, on
peut vous shadow banner, on peut baisser
votre capacité à toucher votre
communauté d'un simple clic. un coup de
fil de politique qu'un contenu qui n'est
pas illégal mais qui dérange ou qui ne
doit pas être sur sur la ou considéré
comme néfaste sur la plateforme, on vous
baisse votre capacité à à être visible
et on vous ne
suivi l'authentification par carte
d'identité pour protéger les enfants de
moins de 15 ans.
Il faut toujours nous protéger les
enfants évidemment et ça vous inspire
quoi ? Pourquoi les partis politiques
européens à l'échelle européenne
demandent ça ? C'est pour protéger
les potiot des méchants pédophiles, des
méchants de propagande où vous y voyez
quelque chose de plus large à la
chinoise en terme de spotage d'opinion
politique, spotage d'opinion
contestataire,
focalisation, cartographie des des
opposants. Si on laisse ce type d'outil
déjà donner nos cartes d'identité à des
plateformes, on sait pas où ça peut
aller, comment c'est sécurisé. Mais si
on laisse cet outil à des partis
politiques qui ne sont pas encore
arrivés dans une énorme crise politique,
ça peut se retourner contre sa propre
population. Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
?
Quel est votre avis là-dessus ?
Ça c'est un très gros sujet et moi ce
que j'aimerais rappeler, c'est que déjà
cette loi finalement a été discutée en
2023. Euh, il y avait aussi, j'ai vu
récemment sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est
pour ça que je faut remercier même des
gens qui sont anonymes qui ont fait ce
travail, je l'ai vu, qui montrai que
depuis 2018, le président Emmanuel
Macron travaillait à voir euh à lutter
contre l'anonymat sur internet et
c'était de l'époque des gilets jaunes.
Donc, il y a et on se rappelle très bien
de l'époque des gilets jaunes où en fait
vous aviez des gens des lambdas qui
sortaient de nulle part qui se filmaient
en disant "On a marre."
Euh il y a eu récemment le les Nicolas,
je sais pas si vous avez suivi au niveau
des taxations et du fruit du travail qui
doit être rendu au français, c'est très
important. Mais les gilets jaunes à
l'époque, c'était dans cette dans cette
dans cet esprit-là. Et donc vous aviez
des gens qui se filmaient sur Facebook à
l'époque hein qui disaient voilà il faut
qu'on sorte, il faut qu'on défende nos
intérêts. Euh et qui faisait des groupes
de rassemblement pour aller sur les
ronds-points comme on l'a tous vécu.
Moi, j'ai été aussi on a bloqué une
autoroute à l'époque en Loren. Vous
aviez des patrons d'entreprise avec des
ouvriers. Ça c'est ce qui est la force.
Je pense que quand il y a vraiment
quelque chose qui se passe et quand on
voit les différentes strates et classes
sociales qui se mettent ensemble, c'est
qu'il y a véritablement un problème.
Mais depuis 2018, après il y a eu la la
crise sanitaire où là on a très bien vu
que c'était prouvé dans les Twitter
files aussi que Elon Musk et et ses
compares sont relayés. On voyait très
bien qu'il y avait un shadow ban, il y
avait des propos qui étaient enlevés, il
y avait tout un un narratif en fait qui
était officiel et tout ce que vous
disiez à côté était interdit. Euh et moi
ce qui me dérange grandement et c'est
encore le cas le cas aujourd'hui, c'est
que sur les grandes questions finalement
il n'y a pas de référendum, il y a pas
de débat que ça soit des experts ou que
ça soit des un lambda et je mettre une
petite pique sur les médias mainstream
mais ils font des forums ou des choses
et finalement ils prennent des des
influenceurs,
des Instagramurs et en fait ce sont les
mêmes à chaque émission et finalement
c'est simplement ils ont analysé que ça
ça a amené une certaine partie de
l'auditoire et de de spectacle ateur et
que ça permettait de faire du flux.
Encore une fois, ils sont esclaves de ça
finalement. C'est-à-dire que s'il y a
pas les audiences, c'est un problème.
Pour revenir sur l'anonymat,
il y a eu des propositions de loi de
supprimer les VPN,
toujours de lutte contre l'anonymat et
en 2023, il y a une loi qui s'appelait
contre la majorité enfin mettre une
majorité numérique. Tous les partis
politiques confondus l'ont voté.
Donc quand on regarde ça, moi j'ai été
regardé en détail, ils avaient pas la
capacité de le faire directement parce
que le blocage c'était l'Union
européenne. On parlait tout à l'heure
des référendums. Évidemment, il y a la
France mais l'entité supranationale,
c'est le c'est l'Europe qui décide. pour
arriver à cette à cette solution parce
que là justement ça a été voté la France
rapionnière en Europe.
Pour arriver à cette solution, il disait
dans la loi, il faut faire une
commission, un rapport qui permettra en
fait de montrer les solutions qui
doivent être faites justement pour cette
majorité numérique et c'est ce qu'ils
ont utilisé finalement pour aller à
l'Union européenne. Et à partir du
moment, c'est bien expliqué encore une
fois où c'est fait, ils ont 3 mois pour
décret ou faire une loi justement pour
que ça puisse se faire. Donc c'est ce
qu'on a eu l'année dernière. Euh
rappelez-vous Clara Chapaz qui était
ministre du numérique, ça pas été une
grande réussite. Il y a eu l'affaire
avec Jean-Portmanov. Moi
personnellement, c'était une affaire que
j'avais suivi parce que ça m'avait
extrêmement touché. Euh et là on voit
qu'ils ont mis des des gens en garde-
vue, il y a des poursuites mais il y a
pas grand-chose qui a été fait. Donc on
se demandait à un moment donné, moi
personnellement, je me demandais si
c'était pas fait pour instrumentaliser
et pousser cette loi. Et on a vu
quand même quelqu'un qui est mort.
Ouais, c'est c'est dramatique.
Qui qui avait l'air de de se faire un
peu martyriser.
Ça faisait des années, hein. Ça faisait
des années. Ça faisait des années que
des gens alertaient. Moi-même, je
l'avais vu à l'époque en 2022. La part
avait alerté.
Voilà. Moi-même en 2022, je le dis
aujourd'hui, j'avais essayé de
contacter, j'ai été le plus loin
possible pour essayer de dire à cette
personne de partir. Ça, j'ai pas réussi.
Je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont impliqués dans cette affaire parce
que ils ont la le même sentiment que
moi. Et ça, on sort du on sort du
spectre politique sur ces questions-là
comme la protection des enfants. Et
c'est là en fait où il y a un paradoxe
et une contradiction, c'est que d'un
côté on vous dit on va protéger les
enfants. On a vu toutes ces histoires de
couteau dans les écoles, on a vu toutes
ces histoires dans les ASE, enfin tout
ce qui est l'ASE, on a vu toutes ces
histoires de harcèlement
social à l'enfance. C'est ça.
Voilà. Exactement. toutes ces histoires
de harcèlement et de cyberharcèlement où
Gabriel Atal aujourd'hui qui est le
porteur de de la loi avec Laor Miller
qui était concerné par le le drame de de
Lucas et ça c'était Media Part qui avait
révélé que finalement il y avait pas eu
d'enquête. Alors je sais pas si ça a été
fait, j'ai pas j'ai pas regardé par la
suite mais finalement le le boulot n'a
pas été fait. Donc venir aujourd'hui
nous dire "Écoutez, vous allez tous
devoir mettre votre carte d'identité
dans une application tierce ou alors que
le gars femme va l'avir au final parce
que ils se mettent en position de lutte
contre les grands les grandes
entreprises technologiques et de
puissance étrangère mais dans un sens
eux-mêmes. Alors peut-être que ce sera
combattu de leur part mais je vois pas
comment ils peuvent faire. La France a
soumise a quand même pas voté pour je
crois. La France a soumise, il est vrai.
J'ai vu Louis Boyard que politiquement
j'apprécie pas beaucoup mais je pense
que c'est une des personnes qui a la la
on va dire la plus de légitimité pour en
parler parce qu'il parle beaucoup aux
jeunes. Il est très suivi
et puis il est surtout très jeune.
Il est très jeune mais sur ces
questions-là il a fait je crois j'ai vu
un long tweet de 400 ou 500000 vues.
J'aurais pu écrire exactement le même.
Donc c'est très bien ce qu'il a fait et
ce sont les arguments qui sont à donnés.
euh que souscouvert en fait de
protection des enfants, on va euh lister
fichiers enfin fichier, on on nous dira
que c'est faux parce que euh ça va
simplement être stocké, que ça va
disparaître, mais ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudra le refaire. Donc il y a pareil
encore une fois une contradiction mais
que pour la protection des enfants, on
est obligé de d'avoir les cartes
d'identité de tout le monde. Et encore
une fois, c'est comme s'il n'y avait
aucune autre solution. dans les autres
solutions. Enfin, et ça c'est un des
sujets que je vous disais au début par
rapport à la liberté et je pense que le
politique en fait s'ingère dans la vie
des Français, c'est qu'au final l'État
va se mettre en comment dire en
intermédiaire
du parent et de l'enfant. C'est lui qui
va décider.
Vous avez pas l'impression que c'est
l'État qui va éduquer vos enfants là ?
Bah c'est un petit peu ce qu'il veut
faire en permanence.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand l'État
commence à vouloir éduquer vos enfants ?
On est dans une démocratie ou on est on
n plus dans une démocratie ?
Moi, je pense que là, on est dans des
bouffées délirantes qui peuvent amener à
des régimes qui peut mettre en échec la
liberté d'expression, la liberté de
conscience et de d'éducation de ses
enfants. Moi, je suis jeune papa, donc
j'ai pas spécialement envie que l'État
s'ingère dans la façon dont je fasse je
fasse l'éducation de de ma fille. Et
encore une fois, c'est-à-dire de décider
ce qui est bien, ce qui est mal.
Évidemment qu'il y a un problème, il
faut quand même le dire aussi,
évidemment qu'il y a un problème avec le
fait que les jeunes soient dans les
salles de classe, utilisent leur
téléphone, fassent des boucles pour
harceler les autres. Euh mais encore une
fois, il y a une responsabilité des
parents. Il y a une possibilité
d'interdire le téléphone. Il y a une
possibilité de sensibiliser les parents
en leur disant il y a des applications
qui existent. J'ai discuté avec
plusieurs personnes qui sont très fortes
dans la tech qui m'ont dit que leurs
enfants, ils avaient entre 13 et 15 ans.
Ils utilisaient des applications pour
voir en direct ce qu'ils avaient, avec
qui il discutaient les applications.
Donc la solution technique, elle existe.
Après, c'est juste une question de
volonté.
Et euh
encore une fois,
je vous le dis, à partir du moment où
cette question de l'anonymat est discuté
depuis 2018, à partir de la question où
on voit un espace médiatico-politique
qui s'effondre de plus en plus, on se
rend bien compte que il y a tout pour
moi, il y a tout un intérêt en fait à ce
qu'il puisse bloquer ça, mettre les gens
face à à un risque d'autocensure parce
que si vous prenez Mais on va faire on
va prendre un exemple tout simple. Vous
prenez des gens qui discutent sur X. On
va nous dire "Oui, ils sont anonymes.
Évidemment que vous avez des gens qui
peuvent faire des ingérence, des bottes
et raconter n'importe quoi." On les
repère assez facilement. Et de toute
façon, moi je le dis, ça ne porte pas
service à tout le monde dans la lutte en
fait de dénoncer quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas dans un pays parce que ça
décrédibilise.
Vous regardez les gens comme ils
s'expriment sur X sous anonymat. Il y a
un masque, on on ne sait pas qui ils
sont, mais il parle avec plus de
sincérité, d'authenticité, même souvent
ça plaît pas. Moi, j'ai pas de problème
avec ce que des gens de gauche, du
centre ou droite discutent et s'énerve.
Mais au moins la on voit la le vrai
visage des gens. Et de l'autre côté, on
va prendre LinkedIn. Vous regardez
LinkedIn, comment les gens s'expriment.
90 % c'est du c'est de l'intelligence
artificielle. Euh c'est euh
je sais c'est de l'entertainment euh de
l'esclavagisme moderne de travailler
dans les entreprises. Donc il y a une
autocensure en fait et si on commence à
essayer de de on va dire de mettre les
gens face à leurs propos de leur faire
peur et de les mettre sous
l'autocensure, ça veut dire qu'il y a un
problème d'opinion qui ne plaît pas
justement à tout cet aspect
médiatico-politique.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Il y a des gens qui pensent que la terre
est plate.
Il y a des gens qui pensent qu'on fait
repousser les oreilles avec un petit jeu
de un petit jeu de célerie.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ça ? C'est un
problème d'éducation ? C'est un problème
de ministère de l'éducation, c'est une
faillite de l'éducation nationale, c'est
une faillite de l'éducation nationale
qui se transmet via les parents.
Il y a plus de consensus scientifique.
Ça vient de quoi ? Qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire ? Il y a deux choses. La première,
c'est que euh normalement sur des
éléments comme ça, c'est pas très
compliqué de contredire. Normalement,
faut pas avoir peur du débat sur ces
questions-là. Et normalement, la
personne quand elle est amenée euh fait
un débat télévisuel euh avec quelqu'un
qui dit que la térépate avec un expert,
ça tient 2 minutes, hein. Donc c'est
terminé. Et et l'autre chose, c'est que
le fait en fait de mettre de la censure,
de créer le doute, de créer ce climat
anxiogène en fait de sur la liberté
d'expression va faire que des gens qui
racontent n'importe quoi vont utiliser
ça aussi pour dire "Vous voyez euh nous
avons raison donc nous sommes censurés"
et au final ça va ça ça n'aide personne
en fait sur le débat public, sur
l'opinion publique. Ça ne sert personne.
On reviendra sur le sujet censure,
authentification, preuve de votre
identité un peu plus tard. Qu'est-ce que
vous les 3 4 c grands risques que vous
avez identifié pour la France ? Quel
quels sont-ils ? Les priorités ? Quel
vont être l'impact pour la population en
général ? Euh je vous laisse déployer
vos arguments et ce que vous avez
identifié.
Il y en a deux qui sont mis en
permanence, c'est le risque économique
et il y en a qui parlent toujours de
l'immigration aussi et c'est un
problème. Moi, je pense que c'est plus
une conséquence qu'une cause. Mais sur
le risque économique, les chiffres, on
les connaît, tout le monde les connaît
par cœur, 3400 milliards de dettes. Euh,
on a un poste de dépense qui est énorme
par exemple et qui a créé énormément de
disputes. Et ça, je vais revenir après.
Mais par exemple, si vous regardez la
retraite, c'est 300 entre 370 et 410
milliards de dépenses par an. Donc ça a
créé tout ce climat avec les Nicolas qui
payent. Beou s'est présenté un moment
devant les Français en leur disant "Vous
voyez, ça va être compliqué, il va
falloir s'attaquer à cette partie-là."
De l'autre côté, vous regardez par
exemple ce qui est donné à la justice,
c'est 10 milliards. C'est complètement
risible à côté. Euh l'éducation, vous
avez je sais plus quel est le montant,
mais ce qu'il faut bien comprendre,
c'est il y a beaucoup de professeurs
aussi qui qui s'attaquent à ce problème
parce qu'il voi que dans la partie du
budget qui a loué à l'éducation, il y a
une partie des retraites qui est aussi
dedans. Et en fait euh ça c'est un faet
parce que
il y a derrière il y a toujours partie
un budget c'est simple he c'est recette
dépense. Si vos dépenses sont élevées,
vous êtes pas capable de couper dans les
dépenses
et investissement
et investissement.
D'autre côté, les recettes sont minimes
ou elles baissent parce que vous faites
des mauvaises réformes. Vous continuez
de presser les actifs, vous continuez de
presser tous les gens qui créent de la
valeur ajoutée. Que ça soit en France,
que ça soit à l'international d'une
fiscalité qui n'est pas du tout cléme.
Vous allez en fait vous assécher parce
que vos dépenses continuent d'augmenter.
Mais ça c'est une idé une idéologie
hein. C'est le pour moi c'est le
socialisme clairement qui est un
problème. Et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
bien comprendre que vous avez des gens
qui sont en Amérique du Sud, Ravir Miley
par exemple quand ça parle de
tronçonneuse, vous avez des gens de
partie de droite qui commencent à en
parler. Moi je je trouve que c'est
primordial. Ça fait deux fois je crois
qu'il présente un budget en excédent,
truc qui n'existe pas en France. Nous,
on a des budgets qui sont toujours
déficitaires. Je crois qu'on va aller
chercher 310 milliards cette année. Euh
et donc il y a il y a vraiment une
idéologie quand on regarde avec ce qui
se passe en Amérique du Sud, je commence
à m'y pencher de plus en plus où vous
avez toute une dynamique et ce qui a
fonctionné avec Ravir Mily, c'est de
dire on est dans un dans un état où il y
a les péronistes, les kirchneristes, les
gens sont pauvres, il y a une inflation
de malade et on a un état qui est trop
gros. Ça a fonctionné parce que c'était
déjà euh un renouvellement de la classe
politique. C'était un c'est un
économiste euh et qu'il arrivait avec la
tronçonneuse et qu'il allait enlever
tous les ministères qui ne servaient à
rien dans le but de dire "On va enlever
tout ce qui est superflu pour pouvoir
redonner le fruit du travail aux
argentins."
Euh derrière aussi ce qu'il faut bien
voir c'est que ce sont des gens on n'est
pas seulement dans de dans du discours
politique, il s'entour en fait
d'économistes, de gens qui descendent un
petit peu de tout ce qui est doctrines
économiques de Hayek. Euh je crois que
c'est Rou Soueto des Soto où il est lié
à lui avec les gens qui travaillent avec
lui et le but c'est de
travailler sur ce pays-là. Alors
évidemment les gens vont vont dire en
contreargument qu'il y a les Américains
qui qui sont venus les aider. C'est un
fait mais ils auraient déjà remboursé
une bonne partie et continu d'avancer.
Mais c'est ça qui est très important,
c'est que ça crée une dynamique, un
espoir. Voilà. Et c'est pour ça que il
faut savoir prendre dans d'autres pays
et tout en restant en l'aimant en en
étant patriote même si j'aime pas
spécifiquement ce mot mais quand on aime
son pays il y a aucun problème à voir ce
qui se passe dans des autres ce qui
fonctionne. Et quand on voit justement
ce nouvel espoir, les gens qui
s'engagent qui essayent de faire quelque
chose ça crée justement la capacité
l'envie de faire l'effort pour redresser
le pays parce que l'Argentine était
vraiment dans un état lamentable. Ça
c'est la première chose sur l'économie,
sur le sur tout ce qui est aspect
immigration. Euh pour faire très simple,
les chiffres, on les a vu récemment, je
crois que c'est 500000
500000 entrant Lego. Vous avez euh New
qui a donné des chiffres mais Bruno
Rotaillot, je crois qu'il disait que
c'était entre quasiment le million de
clandestins.
Euh et on voit clairement que c'est
ouvert au 4 vent en France. Il y a quand
même un sujet peu importe du spectre
politique où on est où euh même c'est
lié au niveau économique si vous faites
venir des cas de vent des gens du du
monde entier euh qui a pas forcément la
place pour pouvoir travailler, pas
pouvoir les accueillir dans des bonnes
conditions.
Les infrastructures,
voilà les infrastructures. Je me promène
à Paris, je vois absolument des gens
dans des dans des tentes. Alors qu'il
fait 4 degrés, je suis avec un énorme
blouson. Enfin, je trouve ça lamentable
en fait. des enfants à la rue.
Voilà, avec des enfants. Euh vous avez
des immeubles, que ça soit les HLM ou
les les bâtiments vides et cetera, mais
on trouve pas de solution en fait pour
pouvoir que les jeunes en même temps
arrivent à la à leur propriété. L'autre
côté, vous avez des gens du monde entier
qui viennent, ça fonctionne pas en fait.
Voilà. Moi, je pense que cette histoire
de modèle social,
pourquoi ça a été fait comme ça ? Alors
à votre avis,
c'était la subordination de vote,
c'était fait pour faire plaisir, c'était
une un besoin de main d'œuvre, c'était
partie d'un bon sentiment.
Moi, je pense que ça commence une
mauvaise lecture.
Ça vient de la de la main d'œuvre à la
base, surtout les années 70. Moi, je
viens de Laoren, hein, pour ça que je
m'appelle John de Laoren. Il y a toute
cette immigration italienne, portugaise
aussi. Si c'est
embrasse la Loren, voilà.
Et l'Alsace,
absolument, toujours euh une région qui
baisse jamais la tête. C'est pour ça que
j'adore ça.
Un des meilleurs foie gras vers
Strasbourg d'ailleurs.
Ah oui ou la quiche le ren on aime bien
me rappeler
la flamen cûche
aussi. On va arrêter les conneries.
Exactement. Et donc vous aviez
énormément de de d'immigrations
italiennes qui venaient qui
travaillaient dans les haut fourneaux à
Florange à Pompé euh et je connais très
bien ça. Et c'est euh des gens qui
venaient le cœur sur la main, qui
travaillaient, qui investissaient en
Italie, qui repartai en Italie ou qui
restaient ici pour construire des
choses. Euh et euh à l'époque, il y
avait tous ces syndicats, ces gétistes,
communistes qui protégeaient leurs
intérêts. Sauf qu'on s'est bien rendu
compte et on le voit aujourd'hui dans la
politique que la gauche et l'extrême
gauche finalement
s'est décalé de tout cet électorat
ouvrier pour aller plus sur le
communautaire. Je trouve que c'est un
problème. Je trouve qu'il y a une
instrumentalisation des ouvriers et de
toutes les communautés. J'espère que les
gens le comprennent. Je pense qu'ils le
comprennent de plus en plus. Moi
personnellement, encore une fois, je
suis pas sectaire. Je discute avec tous
les gens de toutes les religions, de
tous les toutes les opinions politiques
et on sort bien au-dessus du discours
fade et et insipide de ce qu'on peut
entendre à la télé.
En terme de prospective, ça nous met
tout ça ?
Mais ça nous met pour continuer sur ce
sujet, c'est que ils sont vite rendu
compte que en ayant le socialisme et ce
cette défense du communisme euh les
entreprises fermaient finalement. Il y a
eu la mondialisation, il y a eu des
acteurs étrangers qui venaient.
harceleur mital avec la famille mital
hein qui qui reprenait qui euh qui qui
renvoyait en Inde enfin voilà ils ont
ils ont géré ça d'une façon où il y
avait des gens énormément sur le
carreau. Ça a été très mal vécu. C'était
un moteur économique pour la région et
on voit que les votes pareils se
décalent à droite ou au RN aujourd'hui
et qui souhaite une rupture globale en
fait du de ce qui a été fait
politiquement depuis des années. Parce
que si on regarde si depuis euh 30 40
ans par qui nous sommes dirigés, ça
reste quand même similaire. C'est soit
le PS, soit l'UMP, euh le centre
aujourd'hui. Mais dans un sens, ça reste
quand même extrêmement similaire. C'est
pour ça qu'ils font corps dans le dans
l'hémicycle aujourd'hui pour rester en
place.
Qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui est le
dénominateur commun à à ces trois
parties ?
c'est qu'ils pulent, ils fleurissent
quand les taux d'intérêt sont bas et
quand le prix de la calorie, le prix de
l'énergie est bas.
Si vous supprimez les taux d'intérêt
bas, c'estàdire emprunté pour pas cher
et l'énergie pas chère, ces trois
politiques sont éradiquées.
Je suis d'accord et je pense qu'il y a
une paresse intellectuelle et d'effort
sur le fait qu'on se base sur des joyaux
de qui ont été faits pour la France
depuis le général de Gaulle avec le
nucléaire avec
son rayonnement et du tissu industriel
qui a été fait pendant des dizaines
d'années et en fait on a une classe
politique qui est arrivée et qui s'est
juste basée là-dessus. Donc au final, ce
qui est très simple de faire, c'est de
dire comme vous l'avez expliqué au
niveau des calories euh de l'énergie ou
euh des taux d'intérêt,
des taux d'intérêt, d'utiliser la
planche habillée, utiliser le quantité
easing, ce qu'on a vu pendant le la
crise Covid euh et en fait de euh de
survivre politiquement avec ça. Si on
regarde bien ce qu'a fait Emmanuel
Macron entre 2017 et et 2020 qui lui a
permis d'être élu en 2022, c'est qu'il a
utilisé ces instruments là pour dire "On
va arroser tout le monde en chômage
partiel, on va arroser les retraités
parce que comme je vous l'ai dit, c'est
370 milliards, 410 milliards pour qu'ils
s'assurent sur leur électorat. Et
maintenant qu'on arrive en fin de
course, on est en 2026, bientôt 2027, il
faut bien comprendre qu'on va aller,
c'est pour ça qu' c'est pour ça que les
retraités, moi je je les comprends aussi
que ça les ça les dérange parce que
maintenant on va aller les chercher en
disant
maintenant la fête est finie, on va
aller chercher sur votre retraite, on va
aller chercher sur votre épargne parce
que les chiffres sont extrêmement
simples pour faire simple hein, c'est 6
milliards en épargne, 3 milliards 3400
milliards pour la dette. Donc on
comprend très bien qu'il y a une manne
financière que l'État n'arrive pas à
toucher. Le tissu économique, les
industries s'effondrent. Les chiffres
encore une fois, on avait vu qu'il y
avait 60000 faillites en 2009 qui est
une année clé. 68 68000 faillites pour
2025 et ça c'est les échos.
Donc
à partir de ce moment-là, quand on
revient sur l'idée du budget, moi
c'était mon travail ça. C'est-à-dire que
normalement
vous vous pilotez un bateau qui est
votre entreprise ou un état, vous êtes
censé faire des projections, vous êtes
censé devoir projeter combien en recette
vous allez avoir vos dépenses. La
différence c'est que les dépenses quand
vous êtes un état, il y a un aspect
politique derrière. C'est-à-dire que si
vous allez enlever, vous allez faire la
tronçonneuse comme Ravier Miley, vous
allez décevoir des gens. Il y a des gens
qui vont dire "Onlève les sous de ma
poche." Donc à partir de ce moment-là,
politiquement c'est un problème et il
s'appuie encore une fois sur la survie
politique
et et je pense que encore une fois,
c'est sur cet aspect de l'épargne, sur
l'aspect de la transmission qu'ils vont
aller chercher à un moment donné. Moi,
c'est quelque chose que j'alerte depuis
depuis des années. Il y a d'autres
responsables de gens dans les médias qui
le font aussi. Parce que un autre
chiffre qui été donné,
je les aime bien quand même parce que
c'est important, c'est Amélie de
Montchalin quand dans les discussions du
budget qui disait 70 % des pensions qui
ont été versées finissent dans
l'épargne. Donc ils le savent très bien.
Vous avez eu à un moment donné un guys
lighting.
Il faut parler en français aussi,
on va dire. de submerger l'information
en disant
euh il y a quelque chose à faire sur le
sur l'héritage
où il y a une concomitance entre le
centre, la gauche et l'extrême gauche où
ça devient moi je trouve que ça devient
caricatural en disant l'héritage devrait
être interdit, tout devrait être
collectivé collectivisé
alors que quand on travaille c'est pour
sa famille, on a envie que ça quelque
chose reste à ses enfants déjà. Voilà,
c'est déjà enfin si vous regardez, je
sais plus quels sont les planchers mais
je crois que à partir de 500000 c'est
l'enfer et 500000 on y arrive assez vite
en patrimoine avec une maison, un
appart, un grand appartement.
Donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
protéger. On parlait tout à l'heure de
l'authentification sur les réseaux
sociaux, c'est la liberté de pouvoir
avoir ses opinions.
Il y a le fruit du travail tous les mois
avec ce qui est tiré sur le salaire. Et
il y a aussi le fruit du travail, du
labeur de sa vie qu'on veut laisser à
ses enfants ou même si on n pas d'enfant
de le donner à une cause ou quoi dans
son engagement politique ou un
engagement peu importe pour la nature,
enfin ce que vous voulez et que ça
puisse servir. Et ça, encore une fois,
l'État va se substituer, c'est ça le
terme que je cherchais tout à l'heure,
il va se substituer à la conscience
euh à la liberté de conscience des
Français de savoir comment ils utilisent
leur argent, comment ils utilisent leurs
pensées et ça devient un gros problème.
Donc sur le constat. OK. Maintenant, sur
la projection, la prospective, si des
mesures ne sont pas euh prises
drastiquement pour redresser les comptes
publics, redresser le système de santé,
redresser la défense, redresser
l'éducation, redresser la justice, ça
nous emmène où ? Dans un pays tierisé,
dans un pays vendu à la découpe, dans un
pays qui va être sous le jou d'une autre
puissance. Ça ça nous emmène où dans le
détail ? On va avoir les classes
moyennes se faire éradiquer. On va avoir
1 € qui risque de perdre sa capacité en
pouvoir d'achat. On va avoir le FMI. On
va avoir quoi ? Déjà deux exemples très
récents.
Euh je pense que vous avez entendu,
c'est LMB Aerospace je crois qui fait
des matériaux, je sais plus c'est de
ventilation pour tout ce qui était
des pièces détachées pour la défense,
nos sous-marins, le rafale,
ventilateur électrique Exon si je dis
pas de bêtises super calculateur sur
tout ce qui est crypto. Alors on nous
dit qu'on doit devenir pionnier dans
l'IA. Les bijoux de famille sont en
danger avec une tirmontisation, avec une
mauvaise gestion des dépenses, mauvaise
gestion des recettes et on devient la
proie d'investisseur étranger, même de
l'Union européenne derrière parce que il
y a toujours ce projet de
fédéralisation.
On devient une proie faible pour tous
les gens de l'extérieur qui ne vont
contre nos intérêts parce qu'au final
ceux qui en peront le prix, ce seront
les Français.
Et la seule façon d'empêcher ça, c'est
que nous soyons maître de notre destin.
Voilà, d'un côté, il y a l'espoir, mais
il faut savoir rester maître, capitaine
de son avenir quand on gère un pays.
C'est-à-dire qu'on peut pas simplement
calculer la petite semaine de je vais
faire une belle vidéo sur Instagram ou
TikTok et je vais avoir des votes ou
quoi. Il faut réfléchir à 5, 10, 20 ans.
Moi, c'est ça que je faisais à mon
niveau quand je travaillais en
trésorerie pour pour vraiment voir le
cap, les investissements, s'il fallait
réémettre de la dette, s'il fallait
racheter.
Je peux vous couper ?
Oui, je vous en prie.
Quand quand quand vous faisiez de la
prospective, vous utilisiez quoi ? Des
actuaires, vous utilisiez des bases de
données, vous aviez votre propre réseau
d'informateur, vous avez vous aviez
votre propre instinct, vous aviez des
connaissances dans d'autres pays, vous
sentiez les tendances, vous quelle était
cette clé de lecture ? pour anticiper
dans mon dans mon métier dans mon métier
en fait ce qu'il faisait c'est que et
j'ai vu ça dans plusieurs entreprises,
chaque branche en fait où ils avaient
ses usines donnait les informations tous
les jours, ce qui se passait dans la
semaine et ce qui se passait à 3 mois.
il faisaient ils mettaient ça tous les
jours. Donc on voyait les variations, ça
permettait de donner un mois après de
consolider les informations et de voir à
la semaine combien serait la situation
globale en liquidité. Euh et ça
permettait de faire d'autres rapports
avec d'autres d'autres, on va dire
d'autres domaines dans le groupe pour
voir où sera la situation de du groupe
dans 3 mois, 6 mois, 1 an et ça
permettait de donner des stratégies aux
grosses têtes, hein. Voilà. euh et qui
leur donnait un cap de savoir est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir investir sur telle
technologie, est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
rembourser plus notre dette ? Est-ce
qu'on doit émettre plus de dettes
justement pour compenser les pertes que
nous avons fait dans l'année passée ou
les années qui vont venir selon la
démarche ? En fait, il y a plein de
choses qui se mettent ensemble parce que
c'était un groupe français ?
Non, c'était un groupe
c'était multinational. Ouais. À chaque
fois,
il y avait des services de renseignement
qui venaient vous aider en guerre
économique, en renseignement, des
services qui venaient pour aider votre
compétitivité ou pas du tout ?
Il y avait des discussions, moi j'étais
pas impliqué tout ce qui faisait dans
les fusions et acquisitions, mais
surtout aussi par pays. Parce que ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre à mon niveau
où c'était de de gérer la trésorerie,
c'est que par moment aussi vous avez par
exemple de l'argent qui est dans je
crois que c'était au Salvador d'ailleurs
au Salvador à un moment donné, je crois
qu'il voulait mettre les remontées de
dividendes de 15 % à 30 %. Il y avait
des discussions entre des personnes du
groupe avec le cabinet à l'époque euh de
de pouvoir décaler ça, de l'éviter
justement pour permettre en fait de
faire les remontées de fond. Euh après
sur tout le tout l'aspect
échapper à l'impôt.
Comment
pour échapper à l'impôt ?
Oui, toujours. Après encore une fois
quand vous payez un impôt, c'est un état
qui le récupère. Est-ce que c'est
légitime ou pas ? Moi, je considère que
c'est jamais trop légitime, mais parce
que c'est quand même de l'effort qui est
fait par les par les ouvriers, par les
gens qui ont qui ont pensé ça. Mais
je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Non, non, mais vous avez raison,
faut payer les pompiers, faut payer les
infirmières, faut former les médecins,
faut former
Vous laissez une entreprise extérieure
venir sur votre territoire, vous voulez
quand même que enfin ça soit pas ouvert
au cas de vent mais
bah qu'elle participe à l'effort
national pour la santé des gens, les
routes, les lumières, les services
publics, c'est important. Mais le
problème c'est que si à la fin vous
étranglez les entreprises qui viennent
ou alors encore c'est ça le problème de
la France, c'est que en France vous avez
les PME, PMI, tous les gens qui essayent
de faire quelque chose qui sont
étranglés et de l'autre côté vous avez
des grosses sociétés qui vont arriver à
des grands, je dire des grands cabarets
mais tout ce qui est choose friends et
qui discutent et en fait on va leur
faire du taxe enfin de revoir les taxes
ou leur donner des avantages compétitifs
sur les cotisations pendant x années qui
sont discutés avec le gouvernement en En
fait, ils ont un avantage compétitif par
rapport aux gens qui sont là depuis le
début. Le mec qui tient une entreprise,
qui va avoir 50 salariés, qui va faire
du ménage, va payer plus d'impôts en en
pratac, une grosse entreprise qui va
arriver, il y a un problème aussi. Donc
encore une fois,
quand on a tout ça, la fiscalité, si on
ne veut pas la revoir, si on voit que
les entreprise s'en vont, si on voit que
les Français, toute classe confondu,
surtout la classe moyenne quand même, on
va pas se cacher, euh disent qu'il y a
véritablement un problème sur le frais
du travail, faut quand même se poser les
bonnes questions. Il faut quand même se
dire que le cap qui est donné est pas
bon, que à un moment donné, on va amener
le bateau France dans le néant et que
derrière on va être le enfin va y avoir
une coupure directe de de paiement sur
certains services ou alors on va couper
dans le dans la sécurité sociale, dans
l'assurance maladie, les retraites. Au
final, on on raconte des histoires aux
gens mais d'un jour d'un jour ou
l'autre, on leur dira faudra enlever 10
20 %. Si on continue sur cette
trajectoire-là, ça arrivera à un moment
donné, ce n'est pas possible. Ou alors
ça voudra dire qu'on est capable de
s'endetter indéfiniment. Euh sauf que la
différence aujourd'hui c'est que nous
c'est plus par la banque française,
c'est par la banque centrale européenne
qui dirige. Donc si demain la Banque
centrale européenne vous dit "Au final,
vous pouvez pas vous endetter plus de
310 milliards alors que vous continuez
d'augmenter vos dépenses, va y avoir un
problème,
va y avoir un risque de enfin je pense
pas qu'on est près du défaut parce qu'on
est quand même un grand pays.
Quelle est la note de la France ?
selon les
selon les agences de notation, je sais
même plus. Je crois c'est A- ou a moins
moins selon les
selon Fitch ou euh
ça rien de pour je sais plus mais on a
perdu euh ça c'est un sujet aussi euh on
a perdu euh un cran à chaque fois.
Est-ce que vous avez essayé de penser
contre vous-même d'une façon
bienveillante avec ceux qui nous ont
gouverné depuis les 40 dernières années
en interprétant leur décision non pas
comme des cossards qui pratiquent la
subordnation de vote pour alimenter
Pierre Paul Jacques parce queils ont
permis le l'élection le financement de
la campagne où ils ont travaillé à l'œil
où ils ont rendu des services. Est-ce
que vous avez vous avez essayé de penser
avec bienveillance contre vous-même en
leur pardon en leur accordant le
bénéfice du doute qui faisait de
l'endettement parce que le pays était
peut-être au bord de l'explosion et que
si le pays explose parce que il y a une
guerre civile ou parce que il y a des
services publics qui ne sont plus
assurés, on va se retrouver attaquer par
des fonds vautours. On va notre dette va
être attaquée par des fonds vautours.
Notre note de la dette va être encore
plus dégradé. Donc ça va rajouter un un
cercle vicieux encore plus délétaire.
Est-ce que vous avez essayé de faire ça
? Leur trouver pas des excuse mais
essayer de comprendre.
Ouais. Se mettre à leur place
finalement.
Se mettre à leur place.
Et je pense que j'ai essayé je pense que
moi il retardent l'échéance en fait très
clairement. Je pense que tout le monde
s'en est bien rendu compte. C'est gagné
du temps en permanence. La la force de
la France comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure, c'est d'avoir des joyaux qui
sont centenaires
quand ils sont pas volés au Louvre et
qui nous permettent en fait de nous
endetter, de pouvoir de garder une
crédibilité, même si on l'a vu à un
moment donné quand on émet des
obligations pour avoir de la dette, ça
dépasse les taux dépassent la Grèce et
l'Italie maintenant. Alors je sais pas
si ça a rechangé hein, mais ça démontre
bien la tendance.
Et le problème encore une fois, c'est
que si vous continuez dans ces dans cet
esprit-là, on l'a expliqué, il peut y
avoir des coupes sans le décider, sans
être capitaine, vous pouvez avoir le FMI
qui viennent. Vous avez l'Union
européenne qui fait des documents, c'est
les GOP, c'est euh qui vous donne par
exemple la réforme des retraites, ça ils
en parlaient déjà. En gros, c'est
l'Union européenne attend de vous que
vous fassiez des réformes pour que
derrière ça suive. Berou justement quand
il était encore là, il présentait son
budget parce que il y avait un il y
avait un j'allais dire deadline mais on
a pas le droit de dire du enf on doit
dire que du français. il avait un une
date de
butoire
une date butoire justement pour donner
son plan financier de la France, sa
trajectoire pour voir si ça
correspondait à ce que faisait l'Europe
euh et en même temps la la le carnet la
feuille de route que donnait Emmanuel
Macron des 5 % sur la défense parce
qu'en fait ils sont en fait ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est qu'ils sont
tiraillés ils sont tiraillés par l'Union
européenne par le contexte géopolitique
par les objectifs qui sont donnés
politiques également
Berou, c'est ce qu'il disait, je sais
plus, je crois que c'était 40 60
milliards qui demandaient de de baisse
des dépenses parce qu'il fallait qu'il
financent de l'autre côté la défense.
Donc il faut bien aller les chercher.
Habill Paul pour habiller Jacques.
C'est toujours comme ça. Il y a toujours
un toujours un dindon de la farce en
fait en France.
Ça vient de quoi en fait le fait qu'ils
n'agisse que de façon symptomatique ?
parce qu'ils ont pas de clé de lecture,
ils ont pas de prisme de lecture, ils
font pas d'intelligence économique, ils
font pas de guerre économique, il font
pas de prospective, font pas
d'anticipation, ils avancent comme des
borgnes ou comme des aveugles.
Ça vient de quoi quand même ? Ils ont
fait les grandes écoles, ils sont
connectés, ils ont les meilleurs
scientifiques, les meilleures opinions,
les les meilleures écoles pour les
conseillers, les meilleurs conseillers.
Un des grands fléaux de l'Europe et
surtout spécifiquement en France, ce
sont les normes. C'est pour ça qu'il y a
aussi Ravir Milet qui pris en exemple,
c'est tronçonner aussi les normes parce
que quand vous allez regarder, vous
allez sur le site de la Banque de
France, Agence France Trésor, vous allez
peu importe le sujet, il y a toujours
des normes de de réglementation de la
France et la réglementation européenne.
Donc il vous faut des équipes pour
expliquer, pour remplir le rapport la
façon dont dont vous devez le faire,
respecter les ratios quand vous dites de
faire et au final vous perdez du temps
et de l'argent et vous perdez
véritablement
bah le cap encore une fois vous perdez
vraiment le sens des choses et euh moi
je pense que
même s'il y a les meilleures personnes
autour d'eux, il y a quand même une
déconnexion très clairement faut revenir
sur le terrain. Voilà. Vous faites du
terrain. Pardon. Non, je vais engueuler
Montréal. Il était censé mettre un coup
d'huile et il a pas fait.
Je reviens, je reviens à ma question.
Arrête de me déconcentrer.
Vous ayant travaillé dans la finance,
ayant une clé de lecture, ayez étant
étant étant conscient des des menaces et
des dangers qui peuvent impacter le
pays, est-ce que vous avez pris des
mesures proactives pour rassurer vos
gamins, rassurer votre femme,
leur assurer un petit avenir ? Est-ce
que vous pensez à quitter le pays ?
Est-ce que vous avez grâce à votre clé
de lecture votre capacité anticipée,
vous êtes positionné sur x ou y produits
ou investissement ou pays pour pouvoir
avoir un coup d'avance si je vous
comprends bien par rapport au demeurées
qui qui mène notre pays dans l'iceberg.
On a envie on a tous envie de partir à
un moment donné.
Ça dépend
mais
il y en a qui ont envie de se sacrifier.
Je suis plus dans l'idée là. Mais un
sacrifice ou partir ?
Rester. Partir.
C'est accepter de perdre. Certains
diront que c'est pour revenir plus fort
et cetera.
Moi, je considère qu'il faut rester. Je
considère qu'il y a une bataille à faire
culturelle aussi.
Une bataille
quand on aime son pays de s'opposer
justement à ce qu'on dénonce. Moi très
clairement, je l'assume et des gens
m'attaquent là-dessus. Le macronisme,
c'est l'antagonisme. C'est vraiment
quelque chose j'ai toujours lutter
contre. Euh depuis que cette personne
s'est présentée, je me suis toujours
présenté contre contre ça parce que et
ça crée justement beaucoup de problèmes
avec mon entourage au travail ou même
mes amis parce que finalement de mon
profil, j'étais censé être la personne
la plus macroniste qui soit. C'estàd
vous travaillez dans la finance en
trésorerie et vous je trouvais qu'il y
avait la façon don dont la personne est
arrivée. Encore une fois, c'est l'espace
médiatico politique qui a fait ça. On
arrivait à la fin d'un
on arrivait à la fin d'un cycle. En
fait, je vais je vais décaler la
question mais je pense que c'est
important. En 2017, on arrivé à la fin
d'un cycle. ce que dit ce que dit le RN
aujourd'hui, ce qui disait le FN à
l'époque, l'UMPS,
c'est véritablement euh les deux parties
qui se qui se nourrissaient,
qui qui se partageaient le pouvoir et on
arrivait à la fin d'un cycle. Macron
était quand même au PS euh qu'on nous a
imposé avec Hollande,
mais il connaissait ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre aussi, c'est qu'il connaît
très bien ces sujets-l, il connaît très
bien les données financières. Il bossait
dans une commission à Italie en
2007-2008 qui était notamment je crois
sur
tout ce qui est l'industrie. Donc il
connaît parfaitement les chiffres. Après
il est parti à Rothshield, il a bossé
avec le monde, enfin il a fait
augmentation de capital du de le monde,
fusion acquisition là avec Pfizer
Nesley. Après il est revenu en 2012
conseiller d'Hollande, secrétaire
d'État. Après ministre de l'économie, je
crois qu'il avait je sais pas s'il avait
le budget ou un autre mais peu importe.
il connaît bien toutes ces questions-là
et ce que je trouvais quand même
dramatique, c'est que en ayant tous ces
postes, en ayant parce que encore une
fois par rapport à mon métier, on prend
quand même de la hauteur, on voit ce qui
se passe au niveau des recettes et des
dépenses et de continuer dans cet
espritlà, c'est que c'est purement par
de l'idéologie.
C'est purement euh
soit par encore une fois décaler le
temps pour rester au pouvoir ou euh
Quelle était ma question ?
Votre question c'était
quelles sont vos mesures proactives ?
C'estàd vous anticipez pour la France
pour l'Europe une chien ?
Ah oui partir ou pas ? C'était ça la
question
gardesque.
Donc vous vos vos vos anticipations, vos
vos mesures proactives, c'est quoi ?
C'est partir. Vous êtes prépositionné il
y a 25 ans sur l'or et l'argent. Vous
connaissez les nouvelles pépites comme
vous savez qu'il y a la guerre qui
arrive. vous êtes positionné sur
l'armement ou sur les biothèques ou sur
tout un tas de trucs. C'est-à-dire que
pour avoir un esprit libre, il faut
avoir des cartouches bien graillé dans
le chargeur.
C'est-à-dire que si euh vous êtes juste
un gueulard sur Twitter, vous allez vous
faire éteindre par la crise économique,
c'est dommage. Est-ce que vous avez fait
votre propre anticipation
pour vous donner des reins et des
épaules bien larges ? l'indépendance
financière évidemment que j'ai travaillé
je me permettrai pas de faire ça
aujourd'hui.
Je pense qu'il faut aller voir aussi
avec les gens qui ont envie de faire
quelque chose même avec d'autres pays
même si ça peut créer un problème
d'ingérence mais il faut savoir protéger
les intérêts français et on pourra pas
m'attaquer là-dessus parce que général
de Gaulle c'est ce qu'il avait fait à
l'époque. Je me compare pas à lui mais
dans la dans la réflexion c'est celle-ci
pour continuer là où j'étais quand je
parlais du macronisme
non vos mesures proactives à vous et
ensuite si vous voulez mesure c'est de
faire un combat culturel ma mesure
proactive maintenant que je je continue
j'insiste là-dessus c'est de continuer
cette bataille culturelle et
intellectuelle contre toute cette
idéologie
et c'est possible de le faire à moindre
coût sauf qu'on comprend bien qu'on
s'arrête comme vous l'avez expliqué
qu'on peut vous éteindre, on va vous
shadow ban, on va vous assécher
financièrement. Donc ça après c'est la
responsabilité de chacun. C'est la
responsabilité de chacun aussi de
pouvoir soutenir les gens qui le font
parce que si on veut changer les choses,
il faut que tout le monde s'implique.
Soutenez-nous sur Tipi, on a besoin de
vous.
Non mais non mais c'est c'est le fond du
sujet est là aussi. On peut pas
simplement relayer ou enfin déjà c'est
quelque chose parce que des gens ne le
font même pas. Mais il faut savoir
s'impliquer aussi. On aura besoin de
tout le monde. Ça c'est quelque chose ma
moi j'ai commencé en décembre 2021.
C'est la phrase que je dis à tout le
monde depuis le début. On aura besoin de
tout le monde. Et ça c'est cet
investissement là. C'est cette tête de
tout le monde qui permettra que des gens
comme vous comme moi ou d'autres que je
soutiendrai aussi qui pourront continuer
dans ce combat là. Mais tant qu'on aura
pas détruit cette idéologie mauvaise du
socialisme et du macronisme, on n'y
arrivera pas véritablement.
Et le problème et c'est pour ça que
j'insistais là-dessus, les partis
politiques aujourd'hui qui se couchent
devant ces idéologies là en pensant
qu'ils vont être épargnés, ça ne
fonctionnera pas parce qu'à la fin,
quand on arrivera à la tête, enfin quand
ils arriveront à la tête du pays, la
situation économique sera la même. La
situation des flux migratoires sera la
même. La situation de la justice n'a pas
été réformée sera la même. La fiscalité
aussi.
Pour la fiscalité par exemple, si on si
on ne s'attaque pas à ce grand sujet,
vous avez reçu la vente derlen récemment
qui parlait d'un 28e état européen et ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
aujourd'hui nous sommes étranglés par ce
que fait la France au niveau fiscal et
donc il crée toutes les conditions pour
que les entreprises se disent "Je suis
étranglé en France autant que je fasse
mon entreprise avec la fiscalité
européenne dans un marché européen
et au final les États vont même être
c'est ça qui doit doivent nos dirigeants
doivent comprendre ça aussi. Ils vont
même être dépossédés à un moment donné
parce qu'ils ont plus la liberté
économique. C'est tous les frxiteurs qui
expliquent ça et ils ont raison quand
même sur le battre monnaie et cetera
sont plus cette souveraineté économie
sont sympas.
Voilà
sur l'économie, sur la diplomatie
maintenant aussi. Ça c'est un grand
sujet. on est en plein dedans
sur les flux migratoires
et sur la fiscalité encore une fois même
si ça concerne l'économie. Donc on n
plus d'un état, on parlait d'un état qui
est substitué aux citoyens français mais
on a même une entité supranationale qui
va substituer à un état.
Vous avez essayé de penser contre
vous-même avec des bienveillances
une bienveillance envers Ursula
Vanderleyen. Je me fais l'avocat du
diable.
Pas possible. Je me fais l'avocat du
diable. Il faut toujours penser contre
soi-même. Ursula, cette belle gendâme
brillantissime au ministère de la
défense allemand.
Elle arrive à la tête de l'Europe, elle
se dit "Bon, il y a les Chinois, ils ont
pas l'air très cool." Bon, les
Américains, ils ont pas l'air très cool
non plus. Les Russes, ils sont pas très
cool. On s'est fait boouter hors
d'Afrique, on se retrouve au milieu du
gay. Faisons un gros bloc.
Abolissons les scories étatiques de
souveraineté.
en siphonant le pouvoir pour faire un
gros bloc, pour défendre l'Europe, la
main sur le cœur.
Mais nous sommes français enfin je veux
dire à un moment donné vous voulez être
puissant, quel pays en Europe a
dissuasion nucléaire aujourd'hui ? Il y
en a qu'un.
Il y a l'Angleterre,
ils sont plus en Europe, ils ont fait à
côté.
Un truc transatlantique.
Le moteur économique depuis très
longtemps, ça a toujours été la France.
Et moi, il y a il y a deux trucs par
rapport la vanderienne, pardon. Le
premier, c'est les histoires de SMS. Il
y avait pas que Pfizer, hein. Il y en
avait un autre moment, un autre moment
aussi quand elle était dans les
ministères en Allemagne et j'ai mis de
problème. Elle a réussi à avoir la tête
de l'Europe
et euh
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire ? Ursula
Vlienne,
28e état, aspirer les entreprises, la
fiscalité,
l'énergie nucléaire. L'énergie
nucléaire, merci beaucoup. l'énergie
nucléaire, tout le monde a oublié aussi.
Euh il y avait à un moment donné de
sortir le nucléaire d'une espèce de
labellisation, je sais plus c'était quoi
les termes exacts, les gens pourront
vérifier he je dis pas de bêtises, de le
sortir des énergies vertes ou d'un truc
d'un bloc spécifique qui permettait une
une fiscalité spéciale en Europe. Et ça
les Allemands, les les Européens
voulaient nous sortir de ça et en gros
ça allait taper encore une fois contre
les intérêts français.
Ce qui a changé la donne, c'est la
guerre en Ukraine avec la Russie où ils
sont rendus compte qu'il y avait un
danger sur l'énergie et donc que le seul
moteur qui permettait de compenser ça,
c'était la France. Donc la France en
fait on j'aim
beaucoup votre phrase. Ils sont rendus
compte
ils sont rendu compte véritablement
il y avait plus de papier toilette dans
les toilettes.
Si on regarde depuis un certain nombre
d'années, enfin l'histoire de Fonheim
par exemple, ça démontrait bien que
depuis des années, il y avait une
idéologie de fermer les centrales.
En Allemagne, ils ont fait cette erreur,
ils veulent revenir en arrière. Tout le
monde parle de refaire des mini UPR,
même pu faire des trucs étatiques par
entreprise, limite ils veulent faire
tellement les entreprises, les grands
groupes deviennent puissant par rapport
aux États qui réfléchissent à faire ça.
Mais encore une fois, c'est pour ça que
moi je j'arrive pas à me mettre à cette
place- là tout en me disant qu'il y a
une bienveillance à quelconque moment où
il y avait cette attaque qui était fait
contre ça. Encore une fois, c'est les
bijoux de famille de la France.
Et encore une fois, moi j'insiste
là-dessus. Normalement avec ce qui s'est
passé et comme tout le monde bénéficie
du marché européen de l'électricité, ce
qui devraient avoir recevoir les œufs
d'or,
la poule aux œ d'or, c'était la France
sur l'énergie.
Donc encore une fois, on s'est fait
avoir trop naïf par une classe politique
qui est trop naïve.
Certains disent complice, peut-être
qu'elle est complice, mais qui bosse
trop main dans la main avec des
personnes qui vont contre nos intérêts.
Peut-être qu'ils comprennent pas les
intérêts du pays.
Je sais pas honnêtement.
Quelles sont les préconisations, les
solutions à tout ça ? c'est de faire le
frexit,
c'est de faire un parti au-dessus de
tout ça, au-dessus des anciens partis,
c'est d'identifier peut-être des leader
d'opinion avec un cerveau ou un réseau
avec des cerveaux pour les baillassés.
Si vous arrivez à faire ça, vous avez
forcément dépassé
de de la mêlée. Ils vont essayer de vous
neutraliser
vos objectifs personnels certes,
redresser le pays, protéger la France,
protéger les valeurs françaises, mais en
terme de stratégie,
la stratégie la première pour moi, c'est
de créer du lien entre les gens. remet
de la sincérité, de l'authenticité comme
on disait au début parce que c'est
quelque chose qui se perd et ça en fait
justement pour un groupe de personnes
pour amener des choses parce que ça
finalement on en y est même pas encore.
Ça prend du temps. Je vous donne un
exemple par exemple sur
l'authentification sur réseaux sociaux.
Même faire ça c'est compliqué. J'essaie
de le faire en ce moment. J'espère que
quelque chose sortira parce qu'on a bien
vu que la classe politique allait pas
nous aider.
Donc ça c'est un des objectifs à court
terme. Moyen terme c'est encore une fois
de se mettre avec des gens. Il faudra
que soit les gens se mettent avec des
sans étiquettes et qu'un groupe de
français se disent "On va voter pour des
gens sans étiquettes" et encore une fois
moi je donne pas de consigne de vote he
vous votez pour ce que vous voulez pas
de problème avec ça. Les gens on leurs
opinions politiques, je les respecte.
Mais si on veut changer les choses, il
va falloir passer par là. des gens sans
étiquettes avec un programme ou une
ligne établie qui justement sortent du
régime des parties pour pouvoir proposer
autre chose. Envoyer un signal différent
que ça puisse soit quelques bries soient
prise soit qu'il y a un véritable
changement. Moi je pense que ça passera
par là.
Vous connaissez les haut fonctionnaires
?
J'en ai croisé mais
par
ils disent toujours des choses en public
mais en privé ils disent d'autres choses
quoi.
Il y a il y a sur quel sujet ? Bah sur
l'État de la France ou
les
les haut fonctionnaires qui dirigent nos
nos ministères, nos cellules de
prospective, vous vous allez les mettre
dans votre poche ou vous allez les
mettre au pas ?
On aura besoin de tout le monde. S'il y
a des gens qui sont ouverts à aider le
pays, qu'il le fasse. Il y a des gens,
il y a des dinosaures, moi je les
appelle les dinosaures politiques mais
c'est affectueux. Vous avez des gens peu
importe des chevinement, Philippe
Devilier, Guo, je sais pas si vous avez
d'autres noms, enfin peu importe, on
s'en fiche.
Mais avec le recul qu'ils ont,
l'influence qu'ils ont, le réseau qu'ils
ont, normalement il y a une capacité
quand même de faire quelque chose, de
dire "Écoutez, on voit que les jeunes
entre guillemets quarantair ou ceux qui
font dans les cabinets ministériel font
n'importe quoi et cetera, faut remettre
du bon sens dans tout ça, sinon on va
s'effondrer." Et ça concerne pas
simplement une génération, ça sera sur
deux ou trois générations. Donc, il y a
les responsabilités de chacun à prendre.
peut pas simplement se dire euh voilà,
j'ai fait ma vie, euh c'est fini. Ça
concerne tout le monde du plus jeune au
plus vieux, du de pareil encore une fois
des classes sociales à aux classes euh
ouvrières. Et ça par exemple, c'est
c'est ça un truc que les gens
comprennent pas. Pour parler de Donald
Trump par exemple,
Donald Trump, il peut être diabolisé en
permanence et cetera. C'est pas ça le
sujet, qu'on soit d'accord avec lui ou
pas. Là où il a réussi, c'est qu'il a
réussi à prendre les patriotes du haut
et du bas entre guillemets parce que moi
je considère pas que je suis du haut ni
quoi que ce soit, mais qu'il a réussi à
les mettre d'accord sur un projet
commun. Voilà. Et
donc déjà, il y a au niveau de la classe
sociale, donc c'est vertical et vous
avez toute la partie horizontale aussi.
Je crois qu'à un moment donné, il y
avait même les Amiches qui le
soutenaient. Bon, il y avait des
histoires avec eux,
je sais plus dans leur confréie, leur
truc, ça avait créé scandale et ils
avaient tous appelés à voter à voter
Donald Trump par rapport au système qui
se faisait à côté.
Donc c'est là en fait et je pense c'est
ce qui fait peur à énormément de monde
une classe politique qui est établie à
partir du moment où quelqu'un va
t'arriver qui va réussir à faire le lien
de cette façonlà et que il va pouvoir
proposer un projet qui soit clair et de
toute façon dans un pays qui est à sec
financièrement qui a énormément de
division il y a pas 56 solutions quoi.
Faut être ingénieux faut être motivé
faut être déterminé et les solutions
viendront de là.
C'est pas trop tard
c'est jamais trop tard.
La France de toujours, il y en a plein
dans l'histoire qui ont dit que la
France devait disparaître, a jamais
disparu. On est toujours là.
Moi je pense sincèrement qu'il y a
un
on descend tous de quelqu'un. On a tous
une histoire de de partout de là où on
vient. On a tous une histoire. Moi, je
suis sûr que
vous prenez tous les gens qui sont en
France,
ils
souhaitent des choses qui sont toujours
limpides quand on voit dans les sondages
qui puissent être soigné correctement,
la sécurité
vivent de leur travail
et que leur vie soit facilitée avec
moins de normes. Donc entre guillemets,
est-ce que c'est si difficile ?
Franchement parce que là on on se prend
la tête, on discute, il y a énormément
de penseurs et cetera. Est-ce que c'est
si compliqué de mettre des gens à une
table qui soient vraiment décideur et
qui se disent maintenant le budget, on
va le prendre vraiment comme il est. On
enlève toute la partie d'idéologie
politique pour gagner des voies de dire
tel poste ça fonctionne, ça fonctionne
pas parce qu'à un moment donné, il va
falloir faire l'effort, de l'autre côté,
il va falloir recréer du lien parce que
mettre les gens dans des compartiments
selon leur couleur de peau, leur
orientation
de de religion ou quoi que ce soit, moi
je trouve que ça mène strictement à
rien. Même si derrière il y en a qui
parleront de civilisation ou d'autres
choses, mais à un moment donné, il va
falloir créer du lien parce que sinon on
s'en sortira jamais.
Est-ce que c'est si Est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est si compliqué que ça de
faire ? Moi je pense pas.
Question vous nous posez ? Ouais. Alors
nous on répond pas aux questions, on
pose les questions ici. Mais je vais je
vais sortir un peu de mon rôle.
Imaginez-vous la France, l'Europe comme
un avion qui plane.
Ouais. qui n'a plus de carrosène, qui se
fait tirer dessus par ses petits
voisins, qui commence à avoir un
problème de portance,
qui commence à décrocher. Qu'est-ce qui
se passe quand l'avion décroche ? Qu'il
y a plus de moteur, que vous avez pu
aller chercher la ressource ? Qu'est-ce
qui se passe ? va vous écraser.
Et peut-être que ceux qui passent de la
cabine au cockpit essayent simplement de
rassurer et de se faire un petit temps
de vacances au calme en disant que tout
va bien. Peut-être qu'ils sont
conscients que l'avion a plus de ker,
qu'on a 25 trous dans l'aile droite, 25
trous dans l'aile gauche, qu'on a plus
de queue, on a plus de train
atterrissage
et que par contre on a encore le micro
pour chanter que tout va bien ou que ça
va aller.
Vous avez pas l'impression que ça
ressemble à ça ? Quand vous creusez les
facteurs énergétiques de consommation
énergétique, de projection de
consommation énergétique, de projection
d'acquisition de ressources, de métaux,
de bois, de technologie, vous avez pas
l'impression que le gâteau mondial où
cette société thermoindustrielle a pulé
euh
pendant 40 50 60 70 ans ? Ah, le gâteau
s'est bien rétréci que les phénomènes de
guerre économique et géopolitique
rentrent en compte parce que chez les
Russes, chez les Américains, chez les
Chinois, chez les Africains, chez les
Sud-Américains, ils ont le même problème
de consommation exponentielle. Donc, ils
vont aller chercher la ressource chez
lesqu petits copains pour permettre de
continuer à être àur et de proposer des
mesures extraordinaires pour maintenir
ce que vous décriviez. Ouais.
Manger bien, se soigner bien, rouler
bien, tout va bien. Sauf que là, on est
parti dans un monde où c'est chacun pour
soi et Dieu pour tous. Et nous, on a
John Deoren qu'on écoute, qu'on voit, il
relève le menton mais il a pas l'air de
connaître les fondamentaux de
soutenabilité d'une société
thermoindustrielle. Vous on est
bienveillant avec vous parce que vous
débarquez
avec la France chevillée au corps et au
cœur et vous constatez que ce qui reste
au milieu de partis politiques,
bah ils en mangent un peu. La cantine
est bonne et tant qu'on peut faire
perdurer la petite musique avec des taux
d'intérêt, bon ça augmente ça. Les taux
d'intérêt augmentent, ça augmente ça
augmente mais la musique continue. Vous
décrivez que la musique va s'arrêter un
jour et que les français vont ça
continue comme ça.
Bah c'est déjà le cas. Vousz les taux
d'intérêt français à 10 et 30 ans, ils
sont à combien ? On va en en 2030, on va
payer combien de taux d'intérêt ?
Combien de milliards ? 127 déjà 70 on
sera dans les Ouais. 120 130 je pense.
Ouais, un truc du style.
Donc vous vous proposez de fédérer des
vieux dinosaures qui ont le réseau, les
expériences.
Ça c'est un exemple. C'est un exemple.
Mais
un autre exemple, alors
ça répond à votre question.
Ouais, c'est c'est très bien. Il y a pas
de souci avec ça. Dans l'avion qui
s'écrase aussi, il y a un il y a un
petit il y a un petit aéronef qui est
toujours là et que je disais tout à
l'heure, les gens pensent à chaque fois
qu'il va s'écraser, s'écrase jamais.
C'est la France. Donc si on veut à un
moment donné, on peut pas si on peut pas
sauver tout le monde, il va falloir se
sauver soi-même aussi. Faut être
pragmatique, hein. Et si
quatre parachutes dans l'avion.
Comment
il y a quatre parachutes dans l'avion ?
Ouais, mais entre guillemets, le boulot,
il a été fait par nos ancêtres justement
pour ça. Je veux dire, qui a construit
le parc nucléaire, qui a permis qu'il y
ait une dissuasion nucléaire qui fasse
qu'on on soit respecté encore
aujourd'hui dans le monde entier. C'est
par le travail de nos anciens. Donc ça
aussi, il faut savoir en être fier et
faut savoir le péréniser, le protéger.
Et je pense que ça c'est une grosse
problématique qui a été oubliée pour
l'aspect sur la suite. Euh parler
d'énergie, je suis bien d'accord avec
vous sur certains sujets qu'on a
discuté, mais euh il y a toujours le
parc nucléaire,
il y a toujours le fait, comme je vous
ai dit, de la fiscalité. À quel moment
ce serait une impossibilité que vous
revoyez votre fiscalité de permettre les
investissements en France ? Moi, j'ai
bossé à un moment donné au Luxembourg.
Pourquoi on n'est pas capable de dire à
un moment donné bon on a on est au
meilleur endroit du monde. On a les
terres, les mers, les montagnes, on a
tout ce qu'il faut. On a la certain
nombre de populations, les 70 millions.
Fait la meilleure fiscalité du monde et
on amène tous les investisseurs ici pour
créer de l'industrie et recommencer à
faire de la de la recette. C'est pas
possible ça de le faire honnêtement.
Alors évidemment, il y aura le problème
des matériaux mais en étant plus fort
déjà en ayant encore une fois ce parc
nucléaire le dissuasion une parole qui
porte sur le monde, est-ce qu'on serait
si incapable de trouver des alliés pour
pouvoir se créer la logistique, tout ce
qui est nécessaire pour redresser le
pays ? Moi, j'y crois sincèrement que
c'est possible ça. Donc un moment, on
parlait des dinosaures mais il va
falloir aussi que tous les petits génies
qui sont à l'ess HC compagnie et cetera
sortent un petit peu des sentiers battus
aussi qui voient bien la situation du
pays, je suis d'accord avec vous et qui
prennent leur responsabilité parce que
si aujourd'hui la solution c'est juste
d'attendre
et il y avait des chiffres je sais je
sais plus exactement je crois que
c'était 27 % d'augmentation enfin peu
importe la fuite des cerveaux et des des
gens qui ont les les qui ont de l'or
dans les mains s'en vont de la France
Pourquoi ? Toujours la même chose,
l'histoire de la fiscalité, l'histoire
du fruit du travail qui rentre pas dans
les poches. Donc à partir de ce du
moment où ce ce problème là ne sera pas
pris à bras le corps, on pourra pas
avancer. Et ce problème n'est pas pris à
bras le corps, c'est pour ça qu'il faut
revenir par étape à chaque fois parce
qu'il y a une classe politique qui sait
très bien ou qui est déconnecté, qui
prend pas ce souci là parce qu'
justement ils ont préféré diviser les
gens. Alors, on va dire que c'est des
magos, mais ça reste quand même la
vérité. On divise les gens. Le
politique, c'est ça. C'est-à-dire que on
fait d'air, on crée une ligne, faut
jamais sortir de la ligne, hein. Moi, ça
me dérange un petit peu ça aussi, mais
on crée un ennemi. Voilà. Et euh le
centre, les gens qui sont pouvoir en ce
moment, l'ennemi euh selon les jours, il
change. Un jour, c'est le non vacciné,
un jour, c'est le retraité,
un jour, je sais pas moi, peu importe.
Et vous voyez où est le problème quand
on sort de ça, qu'on prend la situation
économique, qu'on voit justement que
tout ça menuise ou que les les les
recettes n'évoluent pas du montant qu'on
l'espère. Quand on a berci, ça c'était
un truc qu'on avait mis sur X qu'on
avait fait exploser à l'époque 2023 2024
euh
60 milliards de dérapage du du de la
dette. Vous vous rappelez de ça ou pas ?
Mauvaise anticipation des rentrées de
TVA. C'est ça
l'étanchéité entre les problèmes
de Bercy et le cabinet du ministre.
C'est ce que disait Bruno Lemire et je
ne sais qui alors qu'ils avaient des
notes du trésor. C'était 20 milliards en
2023, 40 en 2024 je crois. Ellisabeth
Borne et Gabriel Atal. Il y a pas de
conséquence. Il y a pas de conséquence.
Moi je demande même pas que déjà
normalement il y a la CJR, il y a des
trucs et tout mais c'est même pas ça que
je demande. Moi je dis où sont les
solutions ? où sont les recommandations,
les actions pour empêcher ça à l'avenir
? C'est si on regarde aussi depuis les
législatives de 2024 à fin 2025, j'avais
regardé, je crois que c'est
250 milliards ou un truc comme ça de
dette supplémentaire qui a été creusée.
Donc on est on fait du sur place en
fait. On a un monde dans l'aéronef comme
vous disiez. Moi, j'ai pas de problème.
Je trouve que c'est très bien de parler
de ça où tout le monde bouge. J'essaie
de faire des tribunes, j'essaie de faire
des trucs à mon petit niveau, hein. Le
monde est en train de bouger et nous, on
fait du sur place. On est dans un
marécage et on est tiré par nos erreurs
du passé et on veut pas s'extirper et on
pointe un tel ou un tel que c'est sa
faute. Ça fonctionnera pas. Oubliez que
dans le marécage, il y a beaucoup de
sensus quand même hein.
Ouais. Bah après, comme dans tous les
pays, vous avez dans un dans un pays
étatiste des gens qui se servent sur la
dette pour pouvoir se rémunérer. J'avais
regardé aussi, je crois que les toutes
les agences d'État, il y a France
travaille dedans, c'est 135 milliards et
les frais de fonctionnement, c'est 55
milliards à l'année. Donc ne me dites
pas,
ils ont peut-être besoin de ça pour
pouvoir travailler,
mais ne me dites pas que c'est pas
capable de couper là-dedans et qu'on
doit dire aux français vous allez devoir
travailler de jours de plus gratos, il y
a un problème.
Donc si soit on se dit qu'ils sont
complètement incompétents, qu'ils
comprennent rien, soit on se dit que
c'est un chiffon rouge et que derrière
ils font autre chose pour passer
continuer encore d'endter la France,
essayer de gagner du temps.
Peut-être qu'ils essayent de gagner du
temps pour trouver des solutions.
Il faut toujours avoir un une lecture
bienveillante.
Je serais d'accord avec vous. Sauf que
si on regarde tous les sondages
actuellement, même si moi
personnellement, personnellement, j'ai
mon avis là-dessus, je dirai après, mais
il il constate que ça va être un parti
que que ça soit le RN ou probablement le
RN qui aurait le pouvoir en 2027, j'ai
l'impression qu'il se déresponsabilise
de ce qui se passe très clairement parce
que les réformes sont pas faites du
tout. Là par exemple, on a eu le budget
pour 2026, on a on nous a dit "On va
vous laisser voter, on va vous montrer
ce que c'est la démocratie."
Donc on a vu des partis qui votaient
entre eux.
Euh moi c'est là où ça m'a amené
beaucoup de problèmes parce que déjà en
2025, c'était Michel Barni à l'époque,
euh je m'étais amusé à faire tous les
de regarder un petit peu tous les
amendements qui étaient proposés en
commission parce qu'il y a la
commission, après il y a le vote en
séance plainère, ça part au Sénat, ça
revient, il y a il y a quatre parties de
budget en fait hein parce que il y a le
PLF le projet de loi de finance et PLF
SS projet de loi de finance et sécurité
sociale et recette dépenses à chaque
fois en fait. Je crois qu'ils sont même
pas allés à la fin là du coup, ils en
parlaient mais c'est amusant parce qu'on
voit un petit peu l'idéologie des partis
vous disent des choses. Il y en a ils
veulent l' universel, l'autres ils
veulent supprimer le le l'héritage, les
autres ils veulent enlever 100 millions
aux handicapés. Ça, j'avais fait gros
scandale l'année dernière avec ça. Euh
cette année, ils disent "On va aller
chercher, je sais plus c'était quoi les
taux mais euh on va taxer les
multinationales en regardant leur compte
consolidé." Donc l'État français va dire
"Je vais aller voir les grands groupes,
je vais regarder vos comptes consolidés
puis je vais vous dire que c'est ça ma
part." Donc moi, j'expliquais que ça
n'allait pas bien du tout. Voilà, que ça
soit le RN ou quoi que ce soit, c'est
une logique socialiste. C'est-à-dire que
vous avez des gens qui investissent ici
parce que ça aussi c'est par rapport à
mon métier, on va reparler après. Mais
il voi le signal, ils se disent "Mais
attendez, ça veut dire que ici je vais
avoir mes entreprises, ma branche qui
est en France, elle va générer un
déficit.
Euh si derrière de l'autre côté ça fait
des bénéfices puis on va me dire "Ah
non, il y a quand même une part que je
dois payer encore à l'État français
alors que ça ça ne m'apporte strictement
rien." Et moi dans les entreprises où
j'ai bossé dans les grands groupes, il
le disaient très bien. Il y a je me
rappelais à l'époque au niveau du du de
l'énergie parce que ça concerne les
petits comme les gros hein. Moi j'étais
allé voir une entreprise qui faisait de
la charcuterie. J'espère qu'ils se
reconnaîtront. Ils m'ont montré que sa
facture a fait froid 3. Dans le grand
groupe où j'étais, il disait Belgique
France, moins de 100 millions de de
chiffres d'affaires. Mais c'était
compensé. Ils arrivaient à faire les
mêmes chiffres que l'année dernière en
consolidé parce que les autres pays
faisaient mieux. Et il disait "Vous
inquiétez pas, il venait, on avait un on
avait un cocktail et tout et le le
directeur financier, il venait, il
disait "Vous inquiétez pas, on les
fermera pas, on continuera et cetera."
Sauf que les moi qui suivaient, je
voyais qu'il faisait il fermait les
usines, les mettaient en chômage partiel
et là aujourd'hui je sais pas, faudrait
que je regarde hein, mais je dire c'est
à risque que ça va partir parce que si
derrière il y a pas les protections
nécessaires et que ils savent que
derrière il va avoir une taxation
supplémentaire, ils vont pas garder les
gens. Donc il y a un risque de voter des
mauvaises lois même si ça n'arrive pas à
la fin que ça donne un mauvais signal au
business et que à la fin ce sont les
Français qui en qui en pâtissent. Parce
que à un moment donné, on peut vous
faire le procès en disant vous êtes toi
tu es un fils de riche ou tu es riche et
cetera. C'est pas ça. Il faut réfléchir
plus loin que ça. Faut dire que dans le
business derrière, il y a des gens qui
travaillent à tout niveaux et de toute
façon une entreprise qui fonctionne,
c'est à tous les niveaux que ça
fonctionne. Si dans la chaîne il y a un
maillon défaillant, ça fonctionne pas.
Donc si on continue comme ça dans le
socialisme, si on continue à voter des
mauvaises lois, euh si on continue euh
justement à pas écouter la parole des
Français qui essayent de le faire, ceux
qui lèvent le menton comme vous dites,
ceux qui essayent d'apporter justement
du la valeur ajoutée au débat public, on
va continuer, on va continuer de
s'enfoncer.
Faisons une expérience de pensée
ensemble.
Admettons que vous d'une baguette
magique, vous prenez la la place du
calif Skipi à l'Élysée.
Il y a toute une partie de la population
qui vit des subsides de l'État. Si vous
arrivez, vous leur tranchez leurs
subsides, ils vont se retrouver avec
moins de calories dans le frigo. Leurs
enfants, ils vont avoir moins de
calories dans le frigo. Ils vont
peut-être se révolter ces gens-là.
Qu'est-ce que vous faites de ces gens-là
? Vous leur dites "Bon, tu vas te sortir
un petit peu les doigts du fu. Bon, faut
que tu ailles bosser maintenant pour
moins cher, pour plus longtemps, les
gens, ils vont forcément râer. Ils vont
peut-être, j'ai pas terminé,
ils vont peut-être forcément râ
et vous allez leur dire tu râes pas
sinon je te tape dessus ou tu leur dis
bah je peux pas faire autrement sinon la
France va dans le mur et s'ils vous
disent bah on va peut-être voter
ailleurs parce que eux ils nous ont que
ça allait mieux se passer.
Vous faites quoi vous pour passer vos
idées auprès de la population ?
Déjà euh avant de dire on coupe, il faut
trouver une solution de repli.
C'est-à-dire que si vous enlevez des
fonctionnaires et que derrière c'est les
jeté à la rue, c'est sûr qu'on va avoir
des problèmes. Donc il faut créer un
écosystème de business que les gens
puissent trouver du travail. Là on a vu
des chiffres avant que je vienne euh je
crois c'est 2,6 % à l'année en plus de
chômeur par rapport à l'année dernière.
C'est chiffres de NINC.
Encore une fois, si les conditions ne
sont pas faites,
que le travail ne pai pas, que les
entreprises puissent pas investir et et
s'implanter ici, que euh
vous continuez d'arroser des gens qui
sont dans des bureaux où ça n'avance
rien, ça crée pas de productivité, c'est
à la fin c'est tout le monde qui
s'effondre. Donc pour répondre à la
solution par rapport à ça, faut se
mettre pour ça je encore une fois je
prenais l'exemple de Milet, les gens
peuvent pas aimer et cetera, mais c'est
la c'est l'idéologie qui est importante,
c'est de s'entourer d'économistes, c'est
le fait de regarder avec des
spécialistes et des solutions de reprise
pour proposer un projet d'expliquer que
si à un moment donné aussi va y avoir
des difficultés qui vont être faites, il
faut le faire comprendre à la population
et de dire que derrière par contre il y
a un retour sur investissement parce que
encore une fois c'est soit les solutions
en fait la chose elle est extrêmement
simple, c'est soit on continue de déc et
quel est le problème ? Tout le monde
s'effondre. Soit à un moment donné on
fera un effort, on se met sur un projet
ambitieux,
ingénieux, déterminé et on pourra s'en
sortir, peut-être s'en sortir mais au
moins on essaye. Parce que ne pas
essayer, c'est perdre finalement.
Alors là, j'ai j'ai une question
internet de quelqu'un qui râle parce que
on a invité John de Laoren.
D'accord.
Non mais sérieux, Sinkerview, vous
invitez John de Laoren et puis quoi
après ?
Tib in shape les situation. C'est quoi
les situations ? C'est pour si pour
avoir l'opinion des gros tiktur
Guillaume PL est là. Moi j'attends que
vous interviewez des cerveaux pas des
putaqus.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez lui répondre à
cette personne ?
Je peux comprendre le l'énervement,
mais euh
on narrive pas à
pousser des choses sur le débat public.
On n'arrive pas à discuter avec des
députés en les mettant face à leur
contradiction s'il y a pas une colonne
vertébrale et si on réfléchit pas à ce
qu'on fait. Euh moi, c'est à peu près
850 millions d'impressions en un an.
C'est pas que du putaclic, c'est
complètement faux. euh c'est euh de
créer euh les conditions pour que les
choses soient reprises sur le débat
public, de dénoncer les contradiction et
d'essayer de faire avancer les choses.
Tout le monde a encore une fois, on a
besoin de tout le monde. Ce monsieur ou
cette dame qui le dit euh très content
de discuter avec cette personne pour
voir ce qu'elle fait aussi.
Et euh c'est comme ça qu'on avancera
euh parce que il y a tout l'aspect aussi
que vous voyez au niveau public, il y a
aussi tout l'aspect dans les offs où je
discutais avec les gens. Moi j'étais le
premier à pousser dans les offs à faire
une
motion de censure pour Michel Barnier.
Moi, ma stratégie était claire hein et
les députés, je leur expliqué au final
ça a été suivi. Euh c'est de faire
tomber tous les gouvernements successifs
d'Emmanuel Macron jusqu'à ce qu'on le
pousse à la sortie. Ça semble utopique,
sauf que c'était complètement possible.
À un moment donné, ça a pas été suivi.
Il y a eu Hit motions de censure pour
Berérou qui ont pas été faites par
Rassemblement national. Euh
vous avez l'air de le renvouloir un
petit peu
complètement.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est pas du tout le projet
qui était proposé.
Et moi, j'avais fait énormément la
campagne en 2024 de créer un changement
radical parce que les Français euh
veulent un changement radical de
politique. On parlait tout à l'heure de
2017, c'est pour ça que Macron est
arrivé, pour ça que j'en arrivé là, il
s'est présenté comme le sauveur. La
solution différente des experts
économiques. La solution que je vous ai
donné, Macron quand il arrivait, c'est
ce qu'il proposait hein. Mais je suis je
suis complètement à l'inverse parce que
justement c'est la seule solution, c'est
d'arriver par des
par des intervenants extérieur et au
final intérieur comme vous disz les au
fonctionnaires pour créer quand même un
consensus et un projet pour que ça
puisse avancer. Et pour le RN, ils ont
catalysé toute l'opinion dissidente de
ce qui se fait à l'Assemblée nationale
et au final euh moi tout simplement je
regarde ma facture d'électricité, mon
CAD quand je vais dans l'hypermarché, il
continue d'augmenter en fait et il y a
pas les garanties que je souhaitais sur
sur l'Europe, sur la dissuasion
nucléaire. C'est beaucoup trop timide et
il y a un gros problème de contradiction
alors que il y a énormément de gens qui
les ont aidé durant les divers moments
fatidiques des élections et
l'authentification rentre dans ce
problème dans cette problématique là
aussi. Là, j'ai eu un espèce de mini
clash avec Julien Odoule euh qui disait
"Vous travaillez pour la Macronie ou
l'extrême gauche ?" Parce que
c'est qui Julien ?
C'est un député RN.
Je je sais même plus dans quelle région,
je suis désolé. Euh je le salue
d'ailleurs, euh qui me disait "Vous
travaillez pour la Macronie ou l'extrême
gauche Et ce que je voulais faire
comprendre, c'est que même ce parti là
en fait a jouit du fait d'être considéré
comme l'opposition parce qu'il y a
énormément de gens qui s'impliquent
comme probablement la personne, je sais
pas s'il a mis son nom et son prénom
mais le but c'est de pousser les choses
euh
ici on n'est pas en Macronie, on donne
pas le nom des gens
et c'est une bonne chose. Et elle a
raison de poser cette question cette
personne. Et en fait, vous avez
énormément de gens qui sont impliqués
dans l'État ou des agents extérieurs,
enfin dans des entreprises privées qui
ont énormément d'information et qui
veulent apporter des choses. Et par
exemple et justement sur tout ce qui a
été fait pendant la les législatives
européennes, vous avez énormément de
gens anonymes qui apportaient des
informations qui créent le contrefeu
parce que quand vous êtes un parti
d'opposition contre le système entre
guillemets, vous avez le système qui se
met en branle hein. Donc les médias ils
vous diabolisent, vous avez tous les
partis qui se mettent contre vous. Au
final, il vous reste quoi ? Il vous
reste les réseaux sociaux, il vous reste
votre base. Mais au final, en terme de
visibilité médiatique, il vous reste que
les réseaux sociaux.
Donc moi je trouve, je pense que c'est
un coup de poignard qui a été fait aux
électeurs euh
et on parlait du fait que c'était le le
au niveau de l'opposition. Euh il faut
très clairement une solution pour sortir
de de ce socialisme et du macronisme. Il
faut euh comme je disais puisque la
personne attaquée sur l'aspect des
putacliqu, il faut savoir apporter des
choses aussi de ce qui est voté. Moi ce
que ce qui est très important, voilà,
j'y pense, ce que ma volonté aussi quand
j'ai fait le budget où je suis ce qui se
passe dans les assemblées, c'est
d'amener les gens qui me suivent parce
que peut y avoir des à un moment donné
peut y avoir un chat, ça peut vous faire
rigoler et cetera, ça fera mais faudra
m'expliquer pourquoi ça ça fait 2
millions de vues et pas un truc qui va
être super important sur une loi. Donc
il faut savoir jouer avec les deux.
Vous avez posé la question pourquoi les
gens cliquent plus sur les petits chats
que sur des trucs un peu plus arides ?
Parce que c'est la situation est
anxiogène en France. Donc il faut un
ils sont décompressés
ils sont en catatonie émotionnelle parce
que ils vivent l'insécurité, les
embouteillage, le prix de l'électricité,
le prix du cadit.
Ils essayent de jouer dans les règles du
jeu à payer leurs impôts, à essayer
d'élever leur gain et ils ont pas envie
de se faire encore plus emmerder avec
des informations onctionè. Oui,
là vous avez de la chance de vous
exprimer sur une communaut face à une
caméra de communauté affuté, endurci,
forgé depuis des années, qui écoute, qui
essaie de trouver des solutions,
d'identifier tous les points de vue.
Vous parliez de du monsieur du Front
National, comment il s'appelle ?
Odou.
Julien Audou.
Julienou au Front National, il y a il y
a des gens bien quand même. Tongy, il
essaie de bosser.
Ça c'est grand histoire aussi. Enfin ça
c'est non mais c'est lui qui a proposé
les lois que je vous citais tout à
l'heure. C'était dame européenne comment
elle s'appelle ?
Virginie.
Oui, elle essaie de bosser.
Oui, moi j'aime bien Virginie Jeron mais
il y a des votes. Il y a des moments on
voit des votes, ça va pas du tout être
le discours et c'est ça la France à la
France insommise, il y a des gens qui
essayent de bosser aussi.
Ouais mais ça va enfin l'idéologie
chez les républicains aussi il y a des
gens qui essayent de bosser.
Est-ce que vous prenez les meilleures
idées de tout le monde pour essayer de
les catalyser ?
deux choses par rapport à ça.
Vous avez pas l'impression que ces
gens-là, ils ont le syndrome de
Stockholm avec leur parti politique ?
Ils sont tenus par leur partie en fait,
c'est ça le problème. Et moi, à un
moment donné aussi, c'est de mettre tout
le monde. Encore une fois, je faut pas
être dans le sectarisme des meilleures
idées pour dire c'est dans le sens-là
que nous devons aller. Faut faut enlever
l'étiquette en fait. Voilà. Un moment
donné, faudrait limite mettre un moment
donné du boyard avec du David Lisnard à
côté quoi. Ou même du Virginie Jeron et
les gens diraient "Mais en fait, il a
pété un câ mec, il fait n'importe quoi."
Il va falloir distribuer du TRX à tout
le monde dans votre parti. les gens ils
vont dire mais attendez c'est n'importe
quoi. Mais c'est pas la fait le problème
c'est que les gens se mettent derrière
la personne. Mais pour revenir sur ce
qu'on disait quand j'expliquer tout à
l'heure au niveau des postes, le but
aussi c'est par rapport vous parlez de
votre communauté aussi les gens sont
super avertis c'est super. Moi
j'apprécie beaucoup et les gens ils sont
pas de mon opinion politique et ils
m'écoutent ce soir c'est super comme moi
je les écoute aussi mais il faut bien
comprendre que c'est pas la majorité des
gens. Il faut aussi emmener les autres.
Il faut amener les gens à comprendre ce
qui se passe. Quand je disais tout à
l'heure, le politique, il se discute
pas, à un moment donné, il s'impose.
Est-ce que c'est pas trop tard ? Est-ce
que vous avez pas l'impression que le
système est devenu hyper complexe ? Non.
Que les gens ils ont pas le caution
intellectuel ou la formation pour
comprendre ce qui se passe ?
Non, moi je pense que les gens sont
intelligents. L'inverse.
Non, mais on pense que les gens sont
intelligents. Sauf que le système est
devenu tellement intriqué avec la
géopolitique, la finance, les fonds
d'investissement, les caisses de
retraite, le système de santé, l'accès à
l'énergie, aux ressources.
que la France sortie de guerre, c'est
plus ça maintenant,
que le système est vraiment très
compliqué. Nous aussi, on discute avec
des des politiciens.
Bon, ils ont pas fait leur travail de de
vacances, ils connaissent pas les
dossiers, ils connaissent pas
l'intrication de du nucléaire, les
crayons de combustible. Où est-ce qu'on
va chercher dans quelle mine ? Quelle
est la densité de cette mine ? Pourquoi
Trump va au Groenland ?
Les gens, ils envie juste d'élever leurs
gamin, de vivre tranquillement, de payer
leurs impôts, essayer d'avoir des petits
plaisirs simples. Mais le système qu'on
a construit ou que le capitalisme
sur une fonction exponentielle de
consommation a construit, ça c'est
peut-être plus adapté.
Je je suis d'accord avec vous. Mon
argument, vous êtes peut-être Ouais.
Quel avis vous avez sur l'intelligence
artificielle ? Est-ce que c'est une
solution ? Ça sera une solution qui
s'imposera de toute façon. Mais juste
pour revenir un cran en arrière quand
même sur le fait que je disais au niveau
des postes sur X ou peu importe, c'est
d'expliquer aux gens, les amener aussi à
voir ce qui se passe en politique et
qu'ils comprennent le chemin
démocratique d'une loi, comment c'est
discuté, comment le parti fait
l'amendement et cetera. À partir du
moment où c'est fait, c'est fini. Quand
vous disiez tout à l'heure, au niveau de
l'énergie et cetera, moi il y a plein de
sujets je connais pas. Quand je sais
pas, je dis que je ne sais pas. Je
m'instruis, je regarde. Mais à partir du
moment où les wagons sont accrochés,
c'est fini. Voilà, les gens se font leur
propre opinion. À partir du moment où
les gens sont capables de se faire leur
propre opinion, ils ont compris que la
politique s'attaquer à eux, après vous
pouvez avancer et les politique s'ils
font pas le boulot, ils seront
interchangeables. Il y aura d'autres
gens mais il faut aussi la masse des
gens qui puissent mettre cette
personnelà ou un groupe de personnes
pour pouvoir changer les choses. Sinon,
on n'y arrivera pas. Sur l'intelligence
artificielle, ça c'est un sujet qui
s'imposera de devant nous. Je sais pas
si vous avez regardé un petit peu ce
qu'il faisait dans les dans les
administrations publiques. Je sais pas
si c'est avec Mistrral mais je pense que
c'est avec Mistrral. Il regarde de plus
en plus à regarder un peu ce qu'ils
font. Donc ça pareil ça va s'imposer
aussi les discours du centre et de la
gauche en disant vous inquiétez pas on
maintient le nombre de fonctionnaires et
cetera. à un moment donné, ça va
s'imposer parce que il y a euh en fait,
il y a un problème
de garder les voies mais de l'autre
côté, il y a cette volonté comme moi
aussi je faisais en trésorerie comme ce
que fait l'État tous les États et c'est
pour ça qu'il l'authentification. Ils
veulent remonter des datas, remonter des
données. Ils veulent avoir l'info en
direct de ce qui se passe et je pense
que ça il commence un petit peu à le
comprendre ou que la ils sont parlé de
la place du du grand fake enfin de
Macron ou des du responsable du
ministère de de l'économie. À un moment
donné, il faut savoir aussi de de du
haut de voir ce qui se passe en bas.
Donc si on veut que ça fonctionne, il
faut une centralisation de ce qui se
passe. Donc la personne qui est dans son
bureau de la compta qui doit justement
remplir les factures, il doit s'assurer
que ça remonte parfaitement pour que lui
après il puisse naviguer. Donc et ça
coûte énormément en terme de dépenses.
Ils savent qu'à un moment donné, ils
vont devoir couper aussi au niveau des
des dépenses.
l'intelligence artificielle va s'imposer
et même si on vous même si on ne
voudrait pas le faire en France, vous
avez en capital capitalisation boursière
aux États-Unis, c'est truc qui est en
train d'exploser tout ce qui est Nvidia.
Il y avait en Chine aussi travaille
énormément dessus. Il y a tout le
domaine comme vous disiez là des
carburants au minera qui va se lier à ça
aussi. Donc derrière ça c'est euh pour
eux c'est le l'économie du futur,
l'optimisation du futur. Question
internet. Bonsoir John. Pour devenir
candidat aux élections présidentielles,
il faut passer le filtre des 50
signatures des mèes. Ça peut-être un peu
plus ça.
J'ai oublié un zéro. euh des 500
signatures des MRES et être solide
financièrement pour imprimer son flyer
dans des centres de vote. Quel est sa
quelle est sa stratégie en tant que
nobody personne pour passer ce filtre ?
Merci.
Moi personnellement, ce serait très
compliqué mais euh
qu' une banque c'est pas mal.
Ouais. Faut faire du crowfunding, il
faut s'assurer que les gens soient
derrière et il faut faut être viral en
permanence. Le problème de la société au
jour actuelle, c'est que c'est du buzz
et du viral en faitin et euh vous êtes
obligé de passer par là. C'est ça qui me
permet aujourd'hui d'être là ce soir,
qui m'a permis d'être assez news et
cetera, que les gens disent "Tu as pas
de légitimité et cetera." Mais c'est du
travail. Ce qu'il faut bien comprendre,
c'est que derrière encore une fois, faut
la colonne vertébrale, faut de
l'endurance. C'est ce que vous faites
aussi, ça fait des années. Les gens qui
suivent depuis le début, ils savent
quelle est la ligne, quel est le travail
qui est fait derrière, la sincérité,
l'authenticité
et donc
sacerdoce.
Le sacerdoce.
Euh quand on est au quand quand les gens
sont au dos du mur, au pied du mur de
voir comment ils réagissent
et si on veut les sens en signature, ça
passera que par cette solution là.
C'est-à-dire que si vous êtes viral, si
vous avez un candidat,
tous les gens permanents s disent "Mais
attendez, c'est lui qu'il faudrait." Euh
s'il est pas dans les
une parenthèse, si vous me permettez, la
viralité maintenant peut être poussée
par les États d'une façon, nous on
appelle ça de l'astroturfing.
Ouais. Euh donc peut y avoir de la
fausse viralité, peut y avoir des
fausses chaînes YouTube poussées par une
politique étatique pour damer le pion à
ceux qui sont sincères et ainsi de
suite.
Ouais. Ouais, je suis d'accord. Mais ça
ça saute quand même assez vite. Il s'en
rendent quand même assez vite.
Question internet, est-ce que vous
pouvez aborder la situation comex lba,
la monnaie unit, le système brick pay
Swift Brick, la fu de l'afflux de
liquidité via les repos et les dettes
d'État ?
au niveau des bricks, moi je regarde ça,
je vous avoue de de loin, je vois qu'ils
essayent de créer tout un système
connexe et essayer de se décaler de
Swift parce que Swift, c'est évidemment
là où tous les transferts financiers se
font.
C'était quoi la l'autre partie sur les
dépôts ?
Les repos
les repos.
Je rends pas ce qu'il veut comme
question, c'est au niveau du la
rémunération,
la flux de liquidité via les repos et
les dettes d'État.
Ce que je pourrais dire à ce sujet-là,
je suis désolé si j'ai pas bien compris
la question,
c'est que on voit bien que au niveau de
l'endettement aussi euh quand ils
essayent de capter justement l'épargne
des gens ou les investissements, par
exemple le livra,
vous avez
un décalage entre le taux d'endettement.
Vous allez émettre une obligation en
France pour la France.
Les taux d'intérêt vont être de 3, je
dis n'importe quoi, 350 c'est à peu près
ça ou 340. Alors que le livret vous
allez le mettre à 1,75, je crois qu'il a
baissé à 1,50 hein. Je vais ouvrir un
compte récemment là dit que c'était
1,50. Donc le spray le spread, le le la
différence au final va rentrer dans les
poches de l'État. Donc peut-être que les
États enfin je pense que les États en
profitent pour
récupérer encore une mane financière.
Euh et encore une fois, il y a parce que
le sujet là aussi, c'est qu'il y a les
banques centrales qui sont derrière.
C'est un petit peu ce qui gêne Trump, ce
qui gêne
ce qui gêne un peu les États, c'est que
il y a l'inflation d'un côté. Vous avez
les banques centrales qui essayent de
tenir des toits assez faibles pour
pouvoir continuer d'affluer, de mettre
de l'argent dans l'économie de la
planche habillée parce que sinon vous
arrivez pas à tenir votre vos
entreprises.
Donc
ça ça pour moi c'est encore un truc qui
est sous perfusion. On essaie de
maintenir le niveau global parce que
quand on travaille dans les sociétés
côté, vous avez la salle de marché les
la première chose qu'ils essayent de
faire, bon évidemment c'est des coûts
hein pour pour leur pour leur dividend,
pour leur bonus, mais ce qu'ils
essayent, c'est de garder de la
stabilité quoi. Encore une fois,
toujours.
C'est quoi laxe ?
Lax, ça je vous avoue, je sais pas.
On doit y avoir des petits cailloux
jaunes et des petits cailloux argent.
Question internet. Avec sa popularité
a-t-il déjà songé en se rasant le matin
devant le miroir à se présenter à la
députation ? Mais avec qui ?
J'ai des quand je suis allé à SOS, il y
a beaucoup de partis qui m'ont approché
pour ça.
Et
quel parti ?
François, je suis sûr.
Des partis de droite. Il y a des partis
souverainistes aussi qui m'ont approché
et je les respecte tous.
Mais euh
moi je pense qu'il faut que ça vienne de
plus loin encore. Les parties droites en
ce moment sur les chiqu, j'y crois pas
qu'on soit clair. Les partis
souverainistes, je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose à faire mais encore une
fois les
problématiques entre eux où ils arrivent
pas à s'entendre, je pense que ça
dérange tout le monde. Je pense qu'il
faut que ça vienne d'un projet plus
global et que ça soit
ça soit collectif, sinon ce sera pas ça
mènera à rien. Parce que de toute façon
si on narrive pas avec un un projet
clair économique parce que même pour les
les frxiteurs, vous arrivez pas avec le
projet clair qui seront les
personnalités qui géront justement la
sortie de l'euro, la sortie de l'Europe
et cetera. C'est compliqué. Les Français
arrivent pas à se projeter. C'est ça
aussi.
Question internet, méthode simple.
Limiter la libre circulation des
capitaux, taxer les augmentations de
patrimoine, relancer la commande
publique, incitation aux formation aux
formation et carrière technique.
Travailler individuellement plus sans
gagner plus. Question : Qui a le courage
de porter ça ?
De dénoncer, on est d'accord, c'est s de
sa question.
Qui a le courage de porter ça ?
parce que j'ai entendu à un moment donné
de mettre des des taxes. Non,
limiter la libre circulation des
capitaux, taxer les augmentations de
patrimoine, relancer la commande
publique, incitation ou formation et
carrière technique, travailler
individuellement plus sans gagner plus.
En gros, expliquer aux Français qui vont
chier taquet, qu'il va falloir fermer
les frontières, bloquer les capitaux et
que il faut porter tout ça. À votre
avis, qui peut porter ce ces solutions
là ?
Bon courage.
Non, ça je j'ai pas j'ai pas d'idée.
Ouais.
Question internet. Constaat. Il n'existe
que je découvre avec vous. Il n'existe
pas de parti d'opposition de droite en
France. La France n'est plus qu'une
région de l'Union européenne et
retrouver une souveraineté est
essentiellement pour défendre nos
intérêts et notre identité. Mais les
partis dit souverainistes sont divisés.
Quelle horizon ?
Ça c'est la problématique hein et je
pense que Philippe Devilier honnêtement
souhaite y aller. Ça c'est mon intime
conviction
et euh que ce serait une des
personnalités où il serait capable de se
mettre derrière. Mais le sujet de la
droite s en fait il y a un problème
parce que moi je vous ai dit j'ai
sensibilité droite
pas de problème il y a que des
solutions.
La solution arrivera évidemment mais
quand vous regardez à droite aujourd'hui
il y a quand même un affaiblissement une
dilution dans l'Union européenne à
chaque fois et pour moi ça c'est en
contradiction totale avec la
souveraineté ce qui sont les les racines
historiques de la droite et valeurs
conservatrices mettre la France en avant
entre guillemets. Et j'ai vu que ça fait
des années, il y a quand même une grosse
partie de souverainistes à tendance de
de gauche et moi je m'entends très bien
avec eux.
Mais je pense que tout ce que fait
Cercle Aristote,
il y a Non, c'est pas je sais cercle
Aristote, vous avez
euh
même Michel Onf enfin tous ces trucs-là
et on est ces gens-là sont capables de
se parler. Voilà, il y aura à un moment
donné un débat sur euh peut-être
l'immigration euh sur euh le pourcentage
à enlever de telle ou telle mesure, mais
sur le fond en souveraineté, c'est des
gens avec qui on peut aller au front en
disant faut aller gueuler à l'Union
européenne, le marché européen
d'électricité, on va en discuter, le
parapluie nucléaire, OK, mais on va
rediscuter aussi de ce que vous voulez
faire, ce qui a été discuté parce que ça
va pas dans le bon sens pour la France.
Euh tout ce qui est euh au niveau des
relations à l'international, est-ce
qu'on doit forcément s'isolé avec des
pays qui allaient contre nos intérêts
comme l'Allemagne depuis des années ?
Enfin voilà, le coup franco-allemand, il
n'existe pas. Ça c'est un truc c'est un
pour moi c'est un mythe. Je j'ai jamais
compris pourquoi on essaie de faire cro
croire ça aux français. de l'autre côté
euh que ça soit le Merco ou les autres
traités, c'est ça va toujours contre nos
nos prérogatives.
Donc
le grand le grand problème qui sera
réglé, c'est à partir du moment où il y
aura cette droite qui viendra par des
jeunes parce que moi je pense qu'il y a
tout ce qui est la génération de zoomer
et cetera sont beaucoup plus radicaux
encore que ma génération
qui demandera beaucoup plus de
souveraineté et de résultats et de
changement radical
qui créeront un projet avec d'autres
gens qui sont dans un esprit
souverainiste qu'on pourra faire quelque
chose. Soit ça viendra de la
responsabilité des anciens comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure, soit ça viendra
par les jeunes qui créeront une
dynamique, mais le mieux c'est que les
deux se fassent en même temps. Et c'est
je pense que pour moi c'est la seule
solution en France aujourd'hui, c'est
que chacun à un moment donné met son ego
de côté. Encore une fois, on va me dire
c'est bien facile. Mais s capables de
travailler ensemble, qu'on sort en fait
de ce délire des sondages de du calcul à
la petite semaine de
je dois faire la meilleure vidéo TikTok
ou mon passage à la télé pour que ça
marche et au final il y a absolument
rien qui se passe au niveau législatif
et là aprè on pourra faire quelque
chose.
On peut refaire une expérience de pensée
entre nous ?
Ouais.
Bon là je vous écoute et bon ça
ressemble un peu il y a qu'à faucon avec
des s on refait le monde et que machin
il faut qu'il s'entende joli.
Ouais
ça on sent le gars il s'est réveillé un
matin il a mal dormi il a un peu mal aux
fesses parce que il s'est fait taper
dessus et que ça devient compliqué. il a
décidé, c'est quand même un français, il
lève la tête, il dit "Bon ben non, on va
y aller, on va s'expliquer."
Bon, il y a quand même quelques scores,
quelques scornent
un peu sur le système, des mecs qui
profitent du système et j'en passé des
meilleurs autour de la France comme vous
l'avez bien souligné. Il y a Fraoline
Allemagne qui nous met des grands croqu
jambes et puis des il y a Fraine British
qui nous met des grands croqu jambes. On
a quelques copains encore en Europe mais
c'est un peu chacun pour soi et Dieu
pour tous. Et puis autour de cette ce
petit de
on vit dans le passé.
Bon bah il y a les Russes qui ont décidé
de se fâcher genre bien vénère. Il y a
l'autre en Amérique qui a décidé de bien
se fâcher, bien costaud, de nous prendre
les genoux, nous mettre les menottes et
nous faire faire waoua. Ensuite, il y a
les Chinois qui ont décidé de se venger
des Five E des Anglais, des Américains
et qui ont décidé de faire une stratégie
ultra long terme façon au jeu de go
et nous il y a la France. Est-ce qu'il
faudrait expérience de pensée ? Est-ce
que ça va pas se terminer avec un
général qui va lever la tête et qui qui
va dire "Bon, les partis politiques, ça
va 5 minutes, ils nous emmènent dans le
mur. En plus, ils veulent partager notre
souveraineté nucléaire, notre feu
nucléaire pour faire plaisir à Fraoline
Allemagne ou à Fraoline finlandaise ou
suédoise et j'en passai des meilleurs.
Est-ce que ça va pas se terminer par un
petit début de guerre civile avec la
gauche à droite qui vont se mettre un
petit peu sur le nez et puis les
militaires français qui réfléchissent
encore un peu, qui ont les grandes
tendances, qui vont être obligés d'aller
faire les femmes de ménage sur le
terrain parce que ils sont pas capables
d'avoir un ministre des affaires
étrangères ou un qu d'ors ou une cellule
de prospective ou des mecs du
renseignement qui font correctement leur
boulot. Est-ce que ça va pas se terminer
avec un gars habillé en verre qui dit
maintenant vous la fermez bien fort
parce que le premier qui mouffte je vais
me le faire parce que le pays va sombrer
et que vos querelles de petit puceau
tenia à profiter du système le résultat
est le suivant la France coule.
Est-ce que c'est une solution ? C'est
pas une solution ? C'est envisageable ?
C'est pas envisageable ? C'est
souhaitable ? C'est pas souhaitable ?
Moi je pense que le plus sweetup c'est
quelqu'un qui arrive qui tape sur la
table et qui dit maintenant la fête est
finie quoi. Très clairement mais avec un
groupe de personnes qui soit derrière.
Là
il y a Louis Louis Boyard et Julien Odou
qui font oh là là on n'est pas content
c'est pas bien. C'est François Ruffin
qui note les points.
Ouais mais bon le bilan il est là dire à
un moment donné on peut discuter de tout
mais les chiffres sont là. Donc soit euh
on continue et encore une fois ils vont
décaler le problème et euh il y aura pas
de moi je pense pas qu'il y aura de
guerre civile ou en tout cas pas dans
les 5 10 ans mais il y aura une
absorption par l'Union européenne. Il
parle de président européen je ne sais
quoi là qui serait encore plus de
pouvoir cur la vente derleenne. Si on
fait rien qu'on sait
ce sera Macron peut-être qui
voilà peut-être peut-être c'est c'est un
danger très clair. Donc si on fait rien
à un moment donné c'est ce qui va se
passer. On a discuté tout à l'heure du
28e méta européen. Pourquoi garder en
fait des solutions administratives dans
les États ? On sera 10 ju. Non non, il
faut que quelqu'un vienne dire
maintenant la fête est finie, le
socialisme
quel pouvoir avec quel pouvoir quelle
légitimité
quelle légitimité
quel pouvoir
devra repasser par le démocratique hein
parce que moi moi en fait le problème
c'est ça je l'entends très bien que les
gens me disent oui faut reprendre la rue
et cetera mais vous pouvez dégager tous
les gens de la manière forte derrière il
faudra des gens compétents et d'autres
derrière dans toutes les strates de la
société qui vous permettront de faire de
mettre à bien votre projet sinon vous
vous arriverez nulle part ce sera
l'effondrement encore plus rapide ce qui
se passe. dans les pays en Afrique, il y
a le coup d'état. Est-ce que ça se finit
bien pour eux après ? Pas du tout. Donc
si vous avez pas l'intelligence à côté,
vous avez pas un groupe, si vous avez
pas quelqu'un qui porte ça qui dit
maintenant la fête est finie, c'est
cette solution, les gens de cette Europe
et de leur expliquer attendez le truc du
marché européen électricité, on va en
discuter, les flux migratoires, on va en
discuter, on va faire des optaout et
cetera parce que moi ma solution c'est
celle-ci, je préfère la dire là.
Vous arrivez au pouvoir, vous mettez un
ministre de l'Europe ou des affaires
étrangères, il va renégocier tout ce qui
est optout, il va renégocier les
traités. On va vous dire pas,
c'est sortir de tout ce qui est
le la police sur l'économie ou sur le
sur le sur le migratoire. Par exemple,
je crois que c'était le Danemark qui
l'avait fait et dire il y a une il y a
une politique européenne sur telle ou
telle question. Si un pays veut pas
respecter, faut qu'il ait fait un optout
avant ou et je crois que la Hollande
essayait de bosser justement pour en
refaire un alors qu'ils étaient déjà
dans la police du sujet concerné. Mais
moi, je pense que la solution dans tous
les cas passera par quelqu'un qui ira
directement, qui sera un ministre et le
président qui le soutienne qui va
rediscuter les traités en disant
maintenant en France ça fonctionne pas.
Le moteur de la France de l'Europe
pardon, c'est la on parle de l'Allemagne
mais c'est surtout la France parce que
la France sur l'Europe pourra quand même
survivre, l'Europe sans la France ne
pourra pas survivre.
Ces discussions doivent être fait pour
reprendre la main souverainement sur
plusieurs questions et si il y a de
montrer aux Français que il y a quand
même une volonté de montrer que on
essaie de refaire quelque chose parce
que au niveau fiscal peut-être qu'il
nous bloque. Pareil comme je vous ai
dit, il y a les GOP donc derrière il
vous bloquent aussi sur votre politique
économique. Donc en fait c'est qui qui
décide ? C'est qui qui décide en fait ?
Si à chaque fois qu'on vous propose
quelque chose, vous ayez des gens qui
sont à Bruxelles qui vous disent "Ah
non, en fait, il faut que vous fassiez
comme ça." Enfin, c'est juste des
exécutants en fait. Donc s'il y a
quelqu'un qui vient qui veut changer les
choses, il sera obligé de passer par là,
de dire "On va rediscuter toutes ces
questions là, on va mettre des optout.
Si vous êtes pas content, il y a pas de
problème. On a la Constitution en
France, on fait un référendum puis on
verra ce qui se passe." Et moi, je pense
que ils s'arrêteront déjà avant au Levi
en disant "OK, on verra où ça se
passera." S'il décide de pas de de
continuer et d'essayer de d'attaquer les
intérêts français, on arrivera sur la
question du frexit. Ça c'est clair et
net.
Est-ce queil y a un sujet qu'on a pas
abordé que vous souhaiteriez aborder
avec nous ?
Euh le fait que les gens se mettent tout
seul dans des cases, ça je pense que
c'est une grosse problématique.
Euh
mettre tout seul dans les cases ou on
les met dans les cases ?
Les deux. Les deux. Je prenais le métro
pour venir ici. J'avais une jeune fille
qui était à côté de moi qui disait "J'ai
rencontré un jeune homme, il a l'air
super et tout, je sais pas où ça mènera
et cetera." Par contre, j'ai regardé ses
abonnements sur les réseaux sociaux.
"C'est trop à droite, moins c'est mort.
J'essaie de me déconstruire. J'ai pas
encore fini de me déconstruire." C'est
ce qu' expliqué cette jeune fille et je
pense que ça c'est un fléo aujourd'hui
qu'en fait il y a un problème, encore
une fois c'est toujours la même chose.
C'est le projet le projet global
français. les gens direent je je je suis
fier d'être français, ça a été décon
enfin connoté négativement là depuis un
certain nombre d'années. Peut-être
qu'elle lui a rendu service ou
vice-versa hein
peut-être bien évidemment mais les gens
du coup ils ont du mal à s'identifier à
quelque chose et soit ils le font par le
communautarisme
soit par le politique et puis en fait on
s'y perd et c'est-à-dire qu'à chaque
fois qu'on fait ça et cette mauvaise
identification fait qu'en face on voit
un autre ennemi et finalement
on empêche le dialogue. Et d'empêcher le
dialogue aussi, ça c'est encore un autre
fléo, c'est qu'on empêche la résolution
des problèmes. Tout à l'heure, on
parlait du truc de la Terre plate. Si il
y a pas de confrontation en fait des
avis sur les questions, encore une fois,
ça crée du ressentiment, ça crée des
problématiques, ça crée des guerres de
tranché et à la fin tout le monde perd.
tout le monde perd et le le encore c'est
toujours la même chose c'est la personne
qui va se présenter comme le le rempart
des extrêmes des deux de parties dans
les tranchées qui va ramasser la mise et
qui va gérer en fait sur la division et
sur le fait de cette frustration pour
pouvoir de continuer à faire son projet
qui va à l'encontre de tout le monde en
fait ça c'est très simple et encore une
fois si on veut sortir de ça je suis
persuadé et intimement convaincu que
vous avez des gens de gauche et de
droite qui sont capables de se mettre à
une table et dire sur ces sujets-là OK
on s' 'endra pas mais au moins sur 50 60
70 % c'est possible de faire quelque
chose. Ça je ça j'en suis c j'en suis
persuadé mais ça ça c'est encore une
fois c'est la majorité des gens. Si on
prend les tous les militants politiques,
c'est pas possible parce que le la
problématique des politiques aujourd'hui
et euh on me dit euh je fais euh c'est
cette personne me dérange pas parce que
je trouve encore une fois que c'est une
très bonne question que je fais du puta
clic ou quoi. Mais moi je je quand je
prends des positions où j'explique des
problèmes qui ont été faits, on
m'attaque de de m'en prendre à une
personnalité politique mais entre
guillemets, je me prends pas à lui.
Enfin, que ça soit Bardela, Manon Ari,
euh j'en sais rien moi, on s'en fiche.
Mais c'est pas sur la coupe de cheveux
ou on peut se moquer aussi une fois de
temps en temps parce que il nous énerve,
ça on comprend bien mais sur le fond des
idées, c'est pas la personne qu'on vise,
c'est ce qu'elle fait. Quand elle fait
un câlin Ursula Vleyenne, c'est pas
parce qu'elle fait un un câlin Ursula
Vleyen, c'est parce qu'il y a une
proximité alors qu'on dit qu'on veut
s'opposer, qu'il y a des gens, ils se
mettent dans des cases et s'énerve avec
des autres personnes, parfois même des
des gens de leur famille alors que les
politiques ont une proximité entre eux.
Pourquoi ? Parce que encore une fois, il
y a une tiknotisation où comme les
téléréalités, les gens se mettent
derrière des représentations des
personnalités politiques qui deviennent
parce qu'on critique les influenceurs
mais au final ils se comportent comme
des influenceurs. Ils font des vidéos
chez eux, ils font des shorts et et
compagnie, ils reprennent des sujets de
société en disant "Vous avez vous rendez
compte ? Ça c'est un scandale." Il y a
un député que vous avez cité tout à
l'heure, il allait dans un magasin,
"Vous regardez le chocolat, il est cher.
Tu es député mec, qu'est-ce que tu fais
?
Normalement, c'est amendement,
proposition de loi ou alors qu'il fasse
remonter à son parti que derrière ça
apporte une une solution aux français.
Si c'est pour faire du blabla parce
qu'ils savent qu'il y aura pas
d'élection là pour l'instant la dissol
on verra pour la dissolution. Peut-être
que je me trompe, je prends pas de
Paris. Mais euh ils savent qu'ils sont
coincés jusqu'au municipal puis après
2027, les sondages proposent une
tendance. Et si c'est au final parce on
critique la télé, les réseaux sociaux en
disant que c'est occupé le temps de
cerveau disponible, mais la politique
fait quoi en fait si on fait du sur
place en permanence ?
L'événementiel,
on arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Des
livres qui ont été importants pour vous,
pour la construction de votre
raisonnement, pour votre réveil ?
peut-être pour relever le menton et et
regarder les gens droit dans les yeux
pour leur expliquer que vous êtes pas
d'accord. Est-ce que vous avez des
ouvrage ? Et si vous avez pas d'ouvrage
à nous conseiller, peut-être des films
et si vous avez pas de film, peut-être
de la musique.
Je dirais la Bible.
Laquelle ?
Celle
d'arangron, je sais plus c'est quoi le
nom exact. Celle qui est dorée là.
Moi, il y a une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup de Jésus, c'est de dire
"Aimez-vous les uns". Moi, j'ai une
question avant tout ça.
"Vous avez un ami imaginaire ?"
Oui. Il il a quelle forme ?
On le voit pas.
Discuter avec lui, il vous répond.
Comment ça se passe ? C'est
il a une maison, il a pas de maison.
On y croit fermement. Après, je respecte
les gens qui n'y croient pas.
Vous y croyez en latin, pas en latin ?
J'y crois tout court. Moi le
la phrase que tout le monde répète
aimez-vous
donner de l'argent.
Oui.
Aimez-vous de l'argent.
La phrase que tout le monde répète en
permanence de Jésus, c'est "Aimez-vous
les uns les autres ?"
Avez compris ma question ? Pourquoi je
dis ça ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Vous êtes animé par la foi.
Oui.
Chrétienne.
Vous priez ?
Oui.
Ça vous apporte quoi ?
Ça m'apporte que
déjà dans la religion chrétienne, on
explique aussi qu'il y a une grosse
partie de la liberté liberté de
conscience. On
l'am imaginaire comme on dit c'est la
foi. On y croit dans les moments
difficiles de ma vie a toujours été là.
Donc j'y crois fermement.
Euh
à un moment donné j'ai failli passer
hein. Donc c'est je pense que c'est ça
qui m'a qui m'a sauvé en 2016.
Euh
et je pense que quand on croit que tout
est perdu, jamais rien n'est perdu. Et
encore une fois, moi le le j'insiste
là-dessus, la phrase de dire "Aimez-vous
les uns les autres" et après elle est
suivie d'une autre phrase, c'est "Il n'y
a pas de
il n'y a pas plus grand amour que de
donner sa vie pour ses amis."
Et ça pour moi c'est le fondement de ce
que je pense. Il évidemment sa famille,
ma femme et ma fille que j'aime de tout
mon cœur. Mais je me bats pour des idées
qui sont plus grandes que moi. Voilà. Et
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
le font aussi, qui le font dans un but
d'intérêt général, qui le font dans un
but de conviction. Je me rappelle de moi
quand j'étais
en crise sanitaire, je me prenais ma
tête entre mes deux mains en me disant
"Je suis tout seul." Et entre
guillemets, c'est là où j'ai vraiment
fait mon engagement. Je travaillais en
parallèle et j'ai rencontré vraiment des
milliers de personnes, des milliers des
milliers avec qui j'ai discuté et que je
salue,
qui me suivent depuis des années et on
se rend compte qu'on n'est pas tout
seul. Comme vous vous avez créé votre
communauté, on se rend compte qu'on
n'est pas tout seul. Il y en a qui
croient des amis imaginaires, des fois
pas le même. Euh
nous nous euh on a on a les amis
imaginaires, les non amis imaginaires,
les amis imaginair de droite, de gauche.
On a décidé, on leur a expliqué, ici
c'est un terrain neutre, vous essayez
pas de prendre le contrôle de la
dialectique pour rabaisser le votre
prochain.
Jamais.
Et vous discutez entre vous pour essayer
de trouver des solutions. C'était
difficile.
Les câau, nous ce qu'on aime bien avec
les câaux, c'est qu'on peut avoir des
vrais jusatoire,
les pousser dans leur retranchement. et
ils viennent quand même discuter
et et on respecte les câaux pour ça
parce que on connaît les valeurs
catholique et en général ils aiment bien
avoir un échange profond et ils ne se
ils ne sont pas vexés quand on leur fait
le coup de l'amie imaginaire parce
qu'ils aiment parler de leur foi pour
leur expliquer les choses positives que
ça peut leur apporter. quand je vous
taquine avec
Non mais il y a pas de problème bien
sûr. Non mais vous avez raison. Et par
contre dans le sujet de société
actuelle, on a énormément d'églises et
de gens qui sont agressés par rapport à
leur foi chrétienne. Tous les gens de
toutes les fois de judéité ou les
musulmans sont attaqués aussi par
rapport à ça. Mais il y a une pour il y
a une invisibilisation très clairement
de ce qui se passe au niveau des églises
qui toujours les incendies ou les
attaques, les destructions de statues.
Enfin c'est c'est insupportable. Moi je
comprends pas que ça soit pas priable à
le corps et qu'on le dise. Ça pareil,
j'essaie de le faire au maximum aussi.
Vous comprenez pas ? Et si vous
comprenez quand les câa vont commencer à
se fâcher
qui vont dire maintenant ça suffit, ça
va commencer à castagner parce que les
câis signe. Oui,
les câau ils sont en général très
gentils. Ils tendent la joue à droite,
ils tendent la joue à gauche. Bon, quand
ça commence à suffire, ça suffit hein.
Donc si on invisibilise des sujets, à
mon avis c'est pour éviter de mettre le
feu aussi au pays parce que la France
est un pays judéo-chrétien. Il y a des
croix partout, il y a des églises
partout, il y a des cloches partout.
Quand ça va commencer à sonner les
cloches pour y aller, ça va y aller.
Ouais, mais un moment donné, il faut
arrêter
ces attaques quoi. Il faut qu'au moins
quelqu'un se lève contre celle le dise.
C'est pas possible. Si juste pour faire
un tweet ou une communication disant "Oh
là là, c'est un scandale" mais à chaque
fois il se passe rien.
C'est pas possible ça. C'est c'est on se
fait attaquer. Pour revenir sur les
livres aussi, un autre c'est les le
livre en trois parties là de deux goals
sur celui-là. Je l'ai eu là il y a
longtemps pardon sur ces mémoires de
guerre et je trouve que c'est d'autant
plus intéressant de les relire
maintenant et ce que je vais faire après
cette émission euh c'est justement dans
une situation où la France est à genoux
et que il y a des
des pays étrangers qui essayent de faire
un gérant c'est de savoir en tirer le
meilleur de protéger ses intérêts dans
les dans la situation la plus difficile
possible. Et encore une fois, ça
confirme ce que je disais, c'est parce
qu'il a réussi à centurer aussi tout ce
qu'ils ont fait du CNR, hein, Comité
nationale à résistance où ils ont pu
créer un projet et après faire la 5e
République. C'est comme ça qu'on arrive
à changer les choses. Il y a pas
d'autres manières. Il y a pas besoin de
se triturer la tête pendant des années
et des années. Évidemment qu'il y a les
problèmes de matériaux, les problèmes
géopolitiques et cetera, mais c'est un
groupe de personnes, les minorités
actives, quelqu'un qui est devant la
scène, qui pousse les choses, qui prend
les coups aussi. Bien faut bien
comprendre que quand on est exposé, on
prend les coups de partout. On prend des
des coups de pression, on prend des des
coups sous la ceinture, on est en
contact votre employeur,
on vous menace physiquement, on vous
fait de l'intimidation, enfin il y a
tout. Mais si vous êtes avec un groupe
soudé et que demain vous disparaissez,
votre votre idée continue de de
subsister. C'est ça l'importance des
choses. C'est pour ça aussi que quand
vous publiez des interviews, même si ça
peut être des tweetes ou une théologie,
une une idée, un papier, ça reste dans
l'histoire. Il faut laisser une trace.
Et la France, c'est pareil. Il faut
qu'elle laisse une trace. Il faut que
les Français laissent une trace, même si
là c'est compliqué en ce moment, qu'on
puisse arriver à un autre résultat qu'on
essaie de nous emmener actuellement
vraiment. Et le troisème
euh
j'ai eu madame Bovari qui me dit en tête
mais c'est un petit peu imbuvable quoi.
C'est vraiment
c'est vraiment pour dire
un film peut-être
les a franchis.
Pourquoi ? parce que j'aime bien
j'aime bien le le style assez direct et
je dirait aussi même les c'est pas une
c'est pas un film mais une série les
soprano que je conseille aux gens de
regarder où ça met un petit peu parce
que les gens en fait comme les hommes
politiques et tout se font des idées les
influenceurs mais c'est des des vies
comme tout le monde avec les problèmes
de monsieur et madame tout le monde et
nous sommes monsieur et madame tout le
monde euh et de voir un petit peu
comment ça fonctionne
les trahisons, le fait que vous ayez des
groupes qui des amis un jour qui sont
des ennemis le lendemain quand vous
faites de la politique, quand vous êtes
dans
le dans dans le reportage ou l'interview
comme vous faites, voilà, c'est c'est ça
arrive à tout le monde. Il faut bien
comprendre que ça aussi ça existe et je
le conseille parce que c'est encore une
fois ça amène de de l'authenticité et on
voit très bien que c'est faut toujours
avoir une ligne claire dans ce qu'on
fait sinon on n'y arrive pas.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui restera
impérissable sur les réseaux ?
Je leur dirait du trace.
Ouais. Je leur dirai d'utiliser les
l'intelligence artificielle, l'internet
comme il est fait aujourd'hui pour
s'abruver au maximum de connaissance et
de croire en eux vraiment de pas de de
ne pas se faire écraser par toutes ces
personnes qui leur disent que c'est une
c'est une génération de bon à rien.
C'est pas vrai. C'est pas vrai. C'est le
futur. Faudra compter sur eux aussi. Et
je suis certain qu'ils apporteront
beaucoup de choses à la France et que
c'est il y a une responsabilité à nous
aussi de savoir les les insérer dans
cette société. C'est parce qu'on oublie
en fait justement les nouvelles
générations qui arrivent que nous
faisons ces erreurs actuelles.
John de Laoren, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]